you
oh
okay ladies and gentlemen we appear to
be live now we have audio and video
so
i'm representative michael boze chair of
science technology and energy and i
welcome you to our april
5th meeting
please all rise and join representative
thomas as he leads us in the pledge of
allegiance
thank you our purpose here today is to
have public hearings on five bills that
have come over to us from the senate and
i just want to brief everybody about
what our plans are for the rest of the
month
so we will have public hearings today no
executive sessions
next monday april 11th we will have
public hearings again no executive
sessions
on tuesday april 12th we will have a few
public hearings and then executive
sessions in the afternoon the goal will
be to exec about eight bills
so that those bills can come to the
house floor when the house meets on
april 21st
on tuesday april 19th we will have
executive sessions for the remaining
senate bills and those bills will be
able to go to the house floor
on may 5th
cinco de mayo
so that is the plan going forward if you
know that you will be unable to attend
any of the exec session events please
notify your caucus
leader so that
substitutes may be obtained is there a
question representative callie pitts
would you go over that april 12th what
you're going to do executive sessions on
that day
yes we will have executive session in
the afternoon of april 12th in the
afternoon
we have four public hearings in the
morning and early afternoon and then
late afternoon mid-afternoon to the end
executive sessions
you're gonna
may i follow are you gonna are you gonna
follow up with the uh
on april 11th the bills is that are
those the bills you're going to exec on
this 12th
and the reason i'm saying that is
because i've already made an appointment
with an orthopedist for the for late in
the afternoon on the 12th but that won't
make it home
if you're gonna if you're going to exact
late in the afternoon
well you can discuss that with your
caucus leader maybe you need to take
that day off and arrange for a
substitute maybe i need to discuss that
with my chair the way that the way this
the situation goes which bills are you
do you know which bills you're going to
do on april i do i cannot tell you that
all right
the other piece of business that you
need to know about is that there are
senate hearings happening today
concurrent with the hearings that we're
holding here today
so there will be members of senate
energy and natural resources coming over
here and there will be members of our
committee going over there
so people will be coming going coming
and going all day long so don't be
alarmed when you see people get up and
leave
and with that preamble i think we're
ready to begin our work for the day so
i will open the public hearing on house
senate bill 256
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility of replacing the site
evaluation committee and i'll introduce
the bill's sponsor senator geiger
welcome senator
thank you mr chairman for the record
senator bob guy to district 2 vice chair
of senate energy and natural resources
and prime sponsor of
senate bill 256.
prior to commencing the hearing you may
have see me passing out a document
that document is the report of the
committee that met over the summer
chaired by senator ward
to look at the issues relative to the
sec
the results of that were two pieces of
legislation one sponsored by
representative vos the second by myself
256 establishes a committee to study the
feasibility of replacing the site
evaluation committee
this bill is necessary for num for a
number of reasons uh one of which is of
course the evolving department of energy
and defining
as it goes right now its role where it's
going to fit in the in the site
evaluation process
a lot of discussion was held during that
uh that committee meeting over those
committee meetings over the summer so
that's one purpose
uh the second purpose is to look at
funding uh as you know the sec is
uh the business of the sec is done
sporadically there's no pattern of
requests for
for site evaluations to be done so the
funding which is tied generally to
fees is sporadic and so
that's the second purpose we're going to
take a look at with this proposed
committee
and then of course uh look at process
and the authority and the funding of
other organizations similar to our sec
that operate in other states perhaps get
a pattern from them that might work
better than what we have
and of course the role the department of
energy in
in all of this as we
move into what i would call the next
phase of energy development in our state
and with that mr chairman i'd be happy
to take any questions
thank you senator for that excellent
introduction to this bill we have
questions for the senator representative
uh thank you mr chair
i just have one quick question
the
committee it says here in this bill that
the committee has will deliver its final
report
as of a certain date does that
inherently mean that the function of the
committee is over at that point
and if if not
would you be amenable to something in
there that just says that the committee
will end after it submits its final
report
i would think that since the final
report is the final report it would not
be improper to amend this to say that
that the committee goes away
it does have an effective date
i think wouldn't harm the bill to do
that
senator to clarify representative
it appears from the language of the bill
that it does not actually put
this language into statute it just
i've forgotten the term they use now um
dormant
you know chapter law i think is that
that's the
term
so it just becomes chapter law so if it
is chapter law it will expire
with the end of the
calendar year is that true
it will okay thank you
are there any further questions
representative mcgee had a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
um
my concern in the description that you
gave for
um reviewing the sec and whether it
should be
under or rolled in with the department
of energy now that we have a department
of energy
is the same concern that we had when we
first looked at the 80 pages of language
that went into hb2
concerning whether there would be a
bright red line between regulatory
functions and
administrative or executive agency
functions which are
distinct in many ways but the regulatory
i think is intended to be separate so
that there
is no politics played in the discussions
around whether something should be cited
or how it should be cited
so i wonder if you could speak to the
concern that
um
that this
regulatory body although it is used
infrequently uh at least has that bright
red line intact and that um and and
maybe you could just answer whether or
not that would be a consideration that
would be
um kept in place for any committee that
is designed to try and replace what we
have
that's excellent question thank you for
that
uh the
sec is seen now as more of an
adjudicative
rather than regulatory and that's where
we want to go that was the the consensus
of the committee going forward that met
last summer
so i think there'd be very clear line
that the sec would be adjudicative
and as we discussed the department of
energy would be the collector of data
for applications and the monitoring and
enforcement
uh functions would be held over the
department of energy but the sec would
then be strictly adjudicative and
therefore removed from
the process of gathering the evidence
and and the uh the data that they need
follow-up mr chair follow-up thank you
that's helpful the clarification's
helpful so um
so with that being said
if it is an adjudicative body
and the information gathering would be
very similar to how the puc has been
reconfigured right that the department
of energy has the resources now from
that staff and
that would happen there um
i i guess the question would be
um
on
reconstituting the site evaluation
committee
what are the considerations around that
reconstitution in terms of
what would be
changing
i think i'd be less left up to the
committee to determine
again the function of this bill is to
put together a group to look at those
very types of questions
what does the future hold for the sec do
we even have an sec again i'm just
stating this hypothetical questions but
that's the function of the committee is
to sort that stuff out and come up with
the best proposal that will then come
back to the legislature for
and hopefully answer those types of
questions thank you
go ahead representative vincent thank
you mr chairman and thank you senator
for taking my question
uh you had uh touched on um
uh funding
and how sporadic it was um
is it a great cost on the funding can
you give me any ideas
i think the funding depends on the
particular projects but the concern is
maintaining a staff
right that isn't that is not sporadic
okay so how often do these projects come
in not very often right so because of
that there's no general funds that i'm
aware of that are given to this they're
totally self-funded but
not having the ability to level you know
to maintain a stable budget
uh plays havoc with their ability to
function so that's the functionality of
the funding issue that i think will be
looked at how do we fund this more
effectively and there's some some
considerations that were given and
thoughts that were shared during that
committee process but again that would
be looked at by this committee
follow up thank you again
do you so you don't have a figure i mean
if we had to go pack for the last three
years or whatever it was i mean
is it like an over-the-top amount
or is it just uh i'm just trying to
understand um the reasoning for the
funding
well the reason for the funding is to
enable the sec to function no i don't
have specific numbers but those are
available you know from the sec
okay one more follow-up thank you this
has to be the last time i appreciate
that and i understand that this is just
a um
you want to set up a committee to study
study it um
uh and i understand uh what the prior
representative um
asked and i understand your answer
however
in fourth in in the forward thinking
thinking in do you have any
idea on
how
these things would be looked at if you
didn't have
this event if you didn't have this site
evaluation committee
at present time you wouldn't have any
any
capacity to evaluate these projects and
to adjudicate yes or no on these sites
okay they they bring in data from a
number of different sources department
of environmental you know des
transportation in a number of different
departments
we felt that the department of energy
would be the best place to aggregate
that data to then present it
uh to the sec for them to then
adjudicate this is a good site this is
not a good site this needs to be changed
or whatever
again that's a function of the study
committee
we had neither the people nor the
resources nor the time over the course
of this one summer to look into the
depth of those but what came very clear
from our discussions was that we need to
look into this to make this more
efficient
more
rational less political
and i think
the efficiency piece is very important
i thank you senator and thank you mr
chairman thank you representative callie
pitts is recognized for a question
finally
um
this there's a couple of points i'd like
to make first one was
this last line on
page 20 is line 28 who the report goes
to
it doesn't go back to the energy or the
i i would presume that if it goes to the
speaker of the house that being an
energy thing would go to the
energy committee right now technology uh
uh senator guider i would never assume
or presume well that's okay i think i i
think it's your representative
we're here to ask questions to gather
information not to debate and i think it
should be added do you do you present an
amendment
that's your function
so you would not object to that
no but i would object to the tone of the
inquiry
thank you the committee
representative you need a follow-up yes
i do okay october 15th is the date on
this of 2022
and we know that the house
does not meet for two months in the
summer committees etc there's kind of a
a block on those and they do not meet
so i think it's july and august and the
chairman can
can
confirm that it's july and august
so when this committee and if this
committee gets going it will have one
out of this committee that this
committee has i i think has already gone
over haven't they
no the committee has not gone over those
and uh what the house rules are is up to
the house if you think the bill needs
amending then amend it
but we we need this done fairly soon and
i know that there were house members in
attendance at our meetings over the
course of the last summer
so
again
this needs to get done if you feel the
bill should be amended i welcome you to
do so you have the power to do that
all right thank you any further
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
the question
we have another
bill coming over from the senate dealing
with the
what what's your position on
you know one one says let's have a
committee to study what we should do and
the other one says here's what you
should do
could you give us a little insight into
that sure because there were there were
two
there was a short-term and a long-term
look all right the short-term look is
fixed that we need to do right now
to
enhance the efficiency and enable the
continued functionality of the sec in a
way that meets the needs of the public
that's the short-term bill this is the
longer term bill this says okay let's
look long-range and let's take a look at
how we how we structure the relationship
between energy and sec how we fund the
sec and the issues that are presented in
the study committee
follow up thank you very much so
i'm just looking for confirmation that
by
supporting this bill we're not
and that bill we're not creating a
conflict so there there's a definite
sense here of a short term in the long
term and the one does not presuppose the
actions of the other that is correct
thank you very much representative
bernardi is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you
senator gaida um
so as i understand this bill
this committee is going to rev
essentially reassess or revalidate the
the recommendations that
the earlier committee has done quite
comprehensive it looks
and then potentially offer a
bill that would uh
address those and
and turn those
reconsolidated or revalidated findings
into a piece of legislation is that that
do i have that right yes sir you
absolutely do thank you very much
representative samsich is recognized for
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
um and i i think the the last answer was
really
good
useful information
however when i look at the bill it says
we're looking at
a committee to study the feasibility of
replacing the site evaluation committee
when you when you say replacing
are we talking about a new entity
entirely or are we just talking about
absorbing the functions within the
i think that the feasibility
would look at both sides
all right should we keep it as it is
should we change it should we eliminate
it so feasibility meaning
the
[Music]
effectiveness or efficiency of
continuing it forward so i think it'll
look at both sides and that's certainly
the intended legislation just to look at
all possibilities
follow up
oh yes sir thank you and just to clarify
representative vincent's question
are you do you know how many people
currently are
that this comprise the staff of the sec
right now
i do not
i mean is it one person
two people i know i know at least we
have one person probably but uh is it a
dozen i do not know there are other
people who will testify who can probably
answer that question okay thank you very
much thank you senator goddard i want to
thank you for uh introducing the bill
this morning i know you have to get back
to
senate enr we appreciate you being here
sir thank you mr chair members of the
committee
all right
so now we're going to hear from the
assistant commissioner of the
department of environmental services
commissioner mark sanborn to testify in
morning everyone for the record mark
sanborn assistant commissioner new
hampshire department of environmental
services
um wanted to address some of the
questions that come came up
actually no one is working there is no
sec staff right now
um there are zero people
um representative vincent when diane
martin was the commissioner of sec she
did a report on funding needed for it
we'll be happy to get that information
to the committee i've already made a
note to follow up on that
just so everyone knows for the sec
functions
they're funded through the fees
collected by the applicants putting in
to build the sites
and there are many challenges with that
for instance when a
project receives a certificate from the
fcc
part of the sec's responsibility is to
follow up on public complaints
right now that's not funded at all
so there are a number of
existing projects that have complaints
outstanding that when you combine the no
staff with you know the uh and because
even if you had the one staffer who's
more administrative in function you need
to contract out the folks who do the
actual testing do the sound checks or
whatever the nature of the complaint is
um those aren't fun uh funded right now
at all
so
um there are oh by the way just so the
committee knows myself or bob scott who
uh commissioner scott acts as the
uh vice chair of sec in his role we both
served on this committee
um
that came up with these recommendations
so the the gaps in the system are wide
and just so the committee knows
committee members know the way it
functions now if something comes up in
the process that's a des item it gets
referred to us if it's a fish and game
item it gets referred to fish and gabe
and then they handle it um
but if it's one of the if it's one of
the regulatory responsibilities that
specifically comes under the sdc
that's what that committee handles in
terms of responsibility
the the vision we had and center guided
a great job of of
kind of phrasing it we kind of had a two
phase idea with this last committee the
other bill that was mentioned that will
help with some just functions of
the
the existing scc reducing threshold for
quorum because right now it's extremely
hard to get the committee to even meet
some ability to better fund it so it's
just addressing some of the
logistics challenges that exist with it
meeting and it functioning
um the goal of this would be to come up
with longer term solutions
um and to a couple of the questions out
there
a logical
approach to this would be
to
fund a piece of the doe to handle the
regulatory responsibilities
just like
des does for our regulatory
responsibilities just like fish and game
does for their regulatory
responsibilities
and to the question of the bright red
line
i would suggest that this is exactly the
kind of function
doe was meant to perform
just like the department of agriculture
department environmental services
department
of uh of
our fish and game there are there are
regulatory
functions of the state government and
the
correctly staffed department
that has experts in those areas
oversees the permitting process for them
that's how the rest of our state
government functions
and
this is opinion not represented of
myself as an individual
i would actually think it would be less
political
it would function much more of the way
the rest of the regulatory
responsibilities in in our state
function so with that happy to answer
any questions
thank you uh mr sanborn for your
testimony i'll take questions now i
i'll be faster than my answer you're
free to ask a question
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you
commissioner
um how did the sec get here
how do we get to zero people and not be
being able to reply to to complaints uh
in a timely manner uh is it a was it
mainly a matter of of money funding or
was it a matter of
uh somebody not watching what's going on
and all of a sudden everything kind of
blew apart
um
well indeference saw the folks who were
responsible for these and i i'll try and
be
polite in my response it's a combination
of the things you mentioned funding has
always been a a challenge with it
it's an ad hoc group of folks all of
whom including the chair and the vice
chair have other responsibilities you're
the chair is the puc chair the
vice chair is the commissioner of
environmental services
um it's it's
at most it's actual staff was always
only one person
um so it
again this is why i would argue it's
for something as important as energy
infrastructure citing in the state
that's why i'd argue that the current
setup is is inadequate you you
you you don't you you think of all the
other regulatory responsibilities and
the staff that the the state dedicates
to those um and um
and and part of the challenge is its
feet it's completely fee funded which
can certainly work
just like fishing game a lot of our our
department can certainly work fee
structured but it needs a much better
structure than the one it has right now
so we we got here by
it probably
inadequately being set up
and
the
responsibilities of the committee being
larger than originally intended and
never really having a great funding
structure
i seem to recall and i wish
remind me that we
funded
the
sec with an additional funding was it
150 000
for a
staff person
permanent staff person yep and
is that permanence
may i follow up
certainly is that staff person still
there
no
there uh that position has been open
going on you're probably about a year
now no one has filled that that role is
lack of interest
or is it because it wasn't actively
sought to refill that position
there's been a lot of effort i promise
you um to try and find someone to fill
that position
um
it's uh the type of work it
and i know you guys have a lot of bills
in a real short version of the story
um
if
if you want to get a lawyer with a
background
in energy
policy energy law the type of folks that
was desired and
the qualifications of the last person
um
the salary is challenging in that market
and
it's a less known
function
um
there's been a lot of challenges in
terms of recruiting uh to get someone to
fill that role and the other big
challenge is the first person who gets
in there is going to have a whole list
of complaints
of uh
of on pre-existing projects that they're
not going to have any funding to address
so it's it's um
it's not overly attractive at the moment
to go in and you'll be dealing with a
lot of folks who have been waiting over
a year to have their complaint addressed
and you don't have any funding to
follow up on for them
i i need to follow up on that one more
that hundred and fifty thousand dollars
that doesn't doesn't sound like a lot of
money but that hundred and fifty
thousand is additional to anything else
that was collected by fees is that
hundred and fifty thousand dollars still
sitting in obey in some place or yeah it
hasn't been i mean again i'm not
i'm not the accountant for the sec but
the there is funding right now if we
were able to
um if between the commissioner and uh
the chairman of the if we were able to
identify a candidate we would be able to
hire that person
immediately
it's the other functions that wouldn't
be funded
that would make that role
so the role is funded if we if we if
there was someone who was
um who was interested in the job we
could hire that person right now
but
we haven't collected
the sec hasn't collected the necessary
funding on the last estimate and please
don't hold it to me i will get the
committee the report from
diane martin and pam monroe the last
administrator for sec did
but
it would need
a we when we did the committee
we needed like 500 000
uh we needed around 500 000
to follow up to be able to hire the
technicians that would be needed to
follow up on the complaints to to do the
work that would be required in terms of
following up
on the the public inquiries that have
represent little wiki you're free to ask
a question okay thank you mr chairman
thank you um
can you give us an idea of how much on
in an average year is generated by fees
to the sec because clearly
we shouldn't have to fund the whole
thing out of general fund and if there
is some base
line that we can work from then that
would let us have an idea of how it
could work
so
again the report that i'll get you all
is going to be much more illuminating
than my testimony
but
um
it is challenging to
do an average because it's purely based
on the number of
applications so
you
if you if there's a year where there
were three applications to the sec
for a certificate that year's
fee collection is going to be much
higher than a year where it hasn't had
any the sec
hasn't really met in about a year so
there hasn't been any um applications or
collection of
of fees
going on a year now so um that's why
uh we're in we're in a challenge where
we haven't been able to meet quorum just
because of the nature of the membership
um we haven't had an administrator
and we haven't had the funding
to perform the responsibilities of the
sec
representative plett
how do i phrase this a couple of people
have mentioned that it's become
political and maybe
pull back
in my view sec has gone for a body that
reviews an application
and then suggests improvements or
changes to make it acceptable to a
committee of no
and is is the uh
reason why there it hasn't met any years
because it's a committee of no so no
applications are going to be coming
forth
well i would say
there's certainly an element of that
representative i i'd honestly say the
bigger reason it hasn't met for a year
is for most of them
designated members um this is
you know low on their priority list the
the commissioners the state librarian
the the folks who are the the members of
the sec this is a second job and
not their area of expertise for a lot of
them and not their primary of
responsibility and it's just hard to get
seven of them
at any given moment to to meet
and and and be able to have a full
meeting of quorum under the current
statute
so i i'd more lean it towards
for most of the membership this isn't
their primary
responsibility or priority
thank you mr sanborn i have one
okay i was gonna have a final question
but i'll defer to uh representative
pimentel
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question sure um
this
what the sec does is very important to
the people who are waiting to get a
response so that their project can move
forward and
i mean this is the complaint not what
the decisions are but how long it takes
to get them
we've talked about how sporadic
the the work is for the scc because it's
and
so i i my question is
does it make sense to
either
expand the scope of the sec to give them
more work and therefore less
sporadic
or to just
find a suitable
home
for
what is done at the sec
with some other body to kind of
you know so so that there is not that
sporadic nature yeah no no it's a great
question and it is what this committee
would look at
without being too presumptuous and
offering again my individual opinion
versus official administration policy um
i tend to fall in the latter of your two
options um
with the creation of the department of
energy
and you know seeing how the
similar functions on different subject
areas
uh you know the poor mining process
happens at des fish and game agriculture
i think for the
the regulatory permitting
functions of the sec that aren't
assigned to other
other agencies would fit very nicely
at a well-staffed
department of energy that could still be
fee-based you know it doesn't have to
all be funded through the
general fund and um but it would be part
of a department that um could better
structure
an organization
um
with folks who this is their primary
responsibility versus an ad hoc that um
is only administratively attached to
another body
um that doesn't have the resources of
that would be offered by a full
department
thank you um representative mann one one
question please yes thanks um thank you
uh as i recall the
site evaluation committee got started
because of uh northern pass
and p an enormous objection
to people uh to their what would they
they considered a you know an
unreasonably
ugly
transformation of our wonderful forests
so
it does
could the
scope
full scope of a
site evaluation committee could be
contained in
just the department of energy without
bringing in
people representing uh
other perspectives uh interests and so
on
so um
the uh
so the site of actually the committee
actually did exist prior to northern
pass it it was created to address
um like very common in new hampshire you
know very well um it was created to
address a gap
in
in the permitting process the
energy infrastructure
it of course became a lot better known
because of northern pass
and the conversations as a resulting
from that so
um and this committee part of what this
committee would do
is
um
try and
the the public transparency in the
public input is the piece you're talking
about and that
we talked a lot about it
over the summer
and that would certainly be a big part
of the conversation
i will say this
it would have the same public
transparency and the and the same
ability for public input
and um appeals
that
any permit we make right now at des
there every permit we do at des there's
opportunities um for folks to appeal our
decisions and and and and
challenge whether des got it right and
um that would exist and that's the same
the other state agencies and and that
would that could very easily exist with
this thank you thank you
thank you mr sam warren uh say no
further questions
um
appreciate your input yes sir thank you
thank you members of committee and i'll
um
we'll get that report on the funding
that the diane martin had prepared
uh next speaker i have is senator
perkins quoca but i do not see her here
is there anybody here that is
representing her
seeing none i'll move on to the next
speaker is uh mr griffin rohrsch
from department of energy
europe
thank you representative thomas members
of the committee uh for the record
griffin roberge from the
new hampshire department of energy um i
didn't necessarily speak to
sign up to speak on this bill but
now that i'm up here i
answer any questions if there are any i
guess
my apologies uh the cards got mixed up
and your name was next on the list but i
thought it's for a different bill so
you're absolved when speaking if you so
care too or you can say a couple of
words
i mean uh was it obviously the proposed
potentially looking into the feasibility
of creating an office of energy siting
within the department of energy and will
certainly take part in the study
committee should it be created and
signed into law
thank you
questions
see no questions thank you seeing no
other speakers for this bill i will ask
representative vincent by the way
welcome back it's good to see you here
thank you for here i asked can you grab
the blue sheet on this please and turn
there's only one pro here assistant
commissioner mark sanborn from the new
hampshire department of environmental
services okay
that being said
i'd be impatient no problem oh online
sorry do you want to
pass that down or do you want to
announce it i'll just read the online
results if that's okay house bill 256
online is still open until this evening
right now we have foreign support zero
thank you
that being said declared the public
hearing of
next bill is at 11 o'clock so we have a
okay
okay let's get back and start here on
senate bill 440. i'd like to
introduce senator waters uh welcome sir
and you're free to introduce your bill
welcome good morning mr chairman and
members of the committee senator david
waters district four to introduce senate
bill uh 440. this is uh one of a pair of
um offshore wind bills that you're going
to see from me
and they are interlinked so i just want
to mention that at the
at the start
um
by way of some background i know members
of this committee are well aware
of the
development of offshore wind in the gulf
of maine and the great efforts that have
been under
taken by our department of energy and
mark sanborn of assistant commissioner
sanborn of
des we do have an offshore
wind and port development commission
that's been meeting for a couple of
years members of the committee are are
on that and we do have the bureau of
ocean energy management uh task force
meeting for the gulf of maine coming up
on may 19th so a lot going on and i
don't really feel any need to rehearse
what's going on about offshore wind
along the atlantic coast and
particularly in the gulf of maine
because that's that's all out there
this bill is not about
really
what we may or may not think of offshore
wind and how it's coming how it's being
developed it's about protecting new
hampshire's interests
and so what senate bill 440 proposes to
do
is to direct our
still relatively new
office of offshore wind industry
development to look at what criteria we
need to develop that protects new
hampshire ratepayers and our interests
when it comes to that time when we will
begin to see
utilities come in with power purchase
agreements for that power
so that is particularly uh
what this is about
and i will say the state has been
investigating through a number of
studies that
governor sununu
authorized for executive authors and
otherwise to how to properly foster
economic development related offshore
wind and what the powers should be going
forward requiring
cost of energy power purchase agreements
and renewable energy credits and so
forth
and i will note that you know governor
sununu's leadership and offshore wind he
called for the formation of the task
force a couple years ago and that task
force of maine new hampshire and
massachusetts has been has been formed
had one meeting back in december
of uh 2019 and coveted came and now
we're having our next meeting
on may
19th
i will also notice as well that
assistant commissioner
sanborn has taken the lead in making
sure we have additional information the
governor authorized us an rfp to be
done for a really comprehensive study of
the offshore wind industry and we will
shortly have an announcement about that
rfp
so the timing here is is quite good for
this bill we are going to have over the
next six to nine months
a great deal of information
coming through that rfp about everything
that we need to know about offshore wind
and its impacts on
on new hampshire and the timing is also
good for this report because if as the
plan seems to be that we begin to see
lease areas identified
and the auction occurring in 2024
that's the time in which we need to be
ready
to determine what how we will view these
agreements that come
in
so the bill is fairly simple in its uh
statement here you'll see starting on
line seven at the office of offshore
wind
industry development which the
appropriate place for this um shall
consult with the appropriate agencies
receive those reports that are under way
stakeholders utilities and so forth on
and create recommendations regarding
development of clean energy resources
in the gulf of maine
the particulars of this start on line
12.
what should the criteria be for
evaluating power purchase agreements for
and particularly note starting on line
14. here's where we protect new
hampshire's interests
these contracts ought to be
commercially reasonable and then most
importantly cost effective for electric
rate payers in new hampshire
make sure that as we do need to
diversify our
energy sources to make sure that there
is reliability here
and uh that there are environmental
benefits uh and i think particularly
that there are not environmental
consequences um and then also that we
look to contracts that are likely to
help us economically and in terms of
jobs and economic development and not
that those
resources are just going to other states
workers
and secondly and this is
starting on 18 which is relates to what
you're going to see senate bill
that we need to make sure that new
hampshire's interests on fisheries and
the environment are respected in
whatever contracts come forward for the
purchase of offshore win
so this is the interlinking here
that as we if we pass senate bill 268
and we declare consistency under federal
guidelines which means that we have
regulatory authority not just three
miles out but 200 miles out so we can
protect our fisheries and our
environment under that consistency
provision
that then
this
these contracts have to respect the
evaluation made under that consistency
process and this is just crucial
to our environmental and our commercial
and transit interests out in the gulf of
maine
and then finally what are we going to do
about the renewable energy credits that
are produced by offshore wind how are
they they're going to be very valuable
how are they going to be distributed how
are they going to benefit new hampshire
ratepayers
so that's the purpose of the bill mr mr
chairman
it is meant to
make sure the office of
the office of offshore wind industry
development
takes
does his activities here
of course we have that office there
because of the offshore wind
development that's coming along and
that's why
it was passed and that's why the
governor funded it
but i think even more importantly given
the division between the department of
energy and the puc it should be the
department of energy which creates the
criteria for this contract evaluation
because the puc can't do that anymore
and so we will be teed up and ready to
go to to direct the puc as the
legislature should do
as to the criteria to use to evaluate
these resources thank you and i'll take
some questions
thank you senator uh representative
plett you have a question yes i do thank
you uh
or a hand jammer
a
that was a shaky remark
anyway thank you son of the waters for
taking my question uh you mentioned the
office of offshore
in uh what is it in this
site of in the in the department of
energy
offshore wind industry development is
that fully existing fully funded big
enough to handle this now and that's why
there's no fiscal note
yes okay thank you that's all
uh representative harrington
uh thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question senator uh you know i
read through this bill and i say
seems to make pretty much sense to me
but my question is
isn't this what the offshore wind
development uh
agency is supposed to be doing anyways
it's sort of like we're writing a bill
to say go do your job
i don't see much of anything in here
they wouldn't and shouldn't be doing
without legislation normally we don't
unless it's something very unusual or
different we usually don't legislate a
agency to say you'll be like saying des
make sure you issue permits only issue
permits for
a pollution that's within the limits set
by law we don't tell them to do that
because it's implied they will is this
i'm not without disagreeing on the
particulars of the bill is it really
necessary for the bill especially given
that rfp you were talking about
uh thank goodness inheritance you know i
was i was excited there for a minute
when you said you liked the bill and it
seemed to make sense but i was waiting
for the butt okay
and i got it so
um
well here's the thing see what the bill
does is it amends the duties of that
office
because as with the des or elsewhere the
legislature wants to define
what the duties of the various agencies
and offices are so that's why that's why
it's important for this to lay it out
and the particularly mr gemini could
follow because they make this faster so
you're saying it expands and defines
some additional duties to the office
yeah and you've answered my question
and i'm just saying those particulars
are important the consistency references
the cost effectiveness and benefit for
new hampshire these are things i think
the legislature wants to ensure that we
protect new hampshire ratepayers and
this is how we do it
thank you senate waters i have one last
question seeing no others just a
curiosity question
i see nowhere in this bill any reference
to the offshore wooden port authority
development commission
was that intentional or should there not
be some tie-in like sending reports to
that commission as well for instance
well i i thought i thank you for your
question and i thought that um
that was kind of covered in line eight
um you know other relevant stakeholders
i mean certainly that commission will
you know we have a lot of hearings we've
already had a lot of information we can
we can provide i personally think the
most important thing here
is the results we're going to get from
the rfp that assistant commissioner
sanborn has um
has developed with the department of
energy and but yes of course they'll be
involved but that's why i phrased it
that way
okay so there will be interaction
okay great thank you so much thank you
and i have to uh please if any other
questions come up you know where to find
okay mr roberge from department of
energy
thank you chairman thomas members of the
committee for the record uh griffin
roberts from the new hampshire
department of energy
um
the department is neutral on senator
waters senate bill 440.
just by way of background the office of
offshore wind industry development was
originally created i believe and mark
you can correct me
under house bill 1245
in 2020 it was originally housed in the
department of business and economic
affairs but with the reorganization of
the department of energy it was housed
with us under the last budget
so obviously as amended the bill does
two things
in section one it adds a duty to the
office of offshore wind industry
development advising the governor state
agencies
puc and the legislature on the
development of clean energy resources in
the gulf of maine
section two is where it comes down to a
requirement for the individual in the
office of offshore wind industry
development to generate a report based
on the criteria outlined in section two
and that runs from about lines 6 to
24.
on line 25
the office shall issue its report by
june 30th of 2024
uh the report is to be issued by
to a number of entities as outlined in
that section
again while while the department doesn't
take any position on the bill we're
confident that the office uh would be
able to complete the report within the
proposed timeline and as noted in the
fiscal note with existing staff and
existing resources um that concludes my
comments and happy to take any questions
thank you mr roberts i see a question
representative harrington thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so it sounds like you agree
with senator waterstone that there is an
expansion of the duties of the offshore
wind uh department yeah
in looking at it just adds one duty to
clearly advise the governor and state
agencies and public utilities commission
obviously there are other duties part of
that office but i guess you could say
so you know the first no other questions
thank you mr mr griffin thank you i will
morning again for the record mark
sanborn d.s assistant commissioner
i know you guys have a lot of bills just
wanted to really quickly
um reiterate the importance of this bill
along with other senator waters bills
whether you're pro offshore wind neutral
or have concerns with offshore wind
i've been leading our effort in terms of
interacting with boem
and that process because a lot of what
they look at is the environmental side
of this
because this will be happening in
federal waters whether new hampshire
supports
offshore wind in the gulf of maine or
not it could come
so
the critical
why the two bills are critical is the
one
the one ability a state has to make sure
their
um
their impacts to their state and their
constituents are addressed is through
federal consistency if you're a coastal
community a coastal state
but the but the rub with federal
consistency is you can only claim
federal consistency in federal waters if
state legislation exists on that subject
so you can't
you can't talk about
wanting to protect your new hampshire
commercial fishing industry if you don't
have state legislation talking about
doing that if it were to happen in the
three miles off of the state coast
so
the the real importance of senator
waters bills and why we've been working
with them on them is it puts into state
statute
the
issues
um and and how new hampshire would
approach
um compensating commercial fishermen
protecting our environment protecting
uh
you know our approach to offshore wind
so and because it won't happen within
three miles it probably won't even
happen within 20 miles of the coastline
it'll be in federal waters this will
give new hampshire the ability to even
if it's another state and the federal
government moving forward at least have
a voice and a seat at the table so you
know so representative harrington this
gets a little bit to your question the
other reason to get this on
on the wreck in our state statute more
definitively is it would help us if we
had to go to noaa with with uh arguing
state of federal consistency if we
weren't comfortable with the direction
uh a project was going
so i just i just wanted that's a key
part of why we've been working with
senator waters on this and his other
piece of legislation
thank you mr sanborn uh so just for
clarification uh uh pardon me from
stating it three times in other words
this bill would make new hampshire a
stakeholder yes exactly and and and it
would check the boxes needed to be
checked
for us to work with the federal
government
to
assert
um
our approach to these uh if a project
was happening in federal waters because
it is in our state statute if we don't
have it in state statute you can't claim
federal consistency
very good makes sense
representative plett
is there anything consistent about the
federal government
wow we don't have nearly enough time to
okay no seeing no further questions
thank you mr sanborn thank you seeing no
other speakers on the docket i will ask
again representative vincent if he could
okay one is pro is kelly
bucknan
and we have 33 in support
online zero opposed zero neutral it's
still open until tonight for people
watching online who'd like to sign it
with that said i declared the public
hearing for 440 closed
we will
meet again at 11 o'clock
11.
okay
oh
is
um
okay
yes i'm going to call to order
the public hearing for
senate bill
i
am looking to see if any of the
sponsors of the bill are here that would
introduce it
and i do not see any
so what i would do with this point is
out of courtesy i will introduce the
bill
and then
we can
either
well i would say recess until they got
here but i think it's getting kind of
late so we can just go ahead with
some of our speakers that we have listed
here
introducing senate bill 259 relative to
the definition of municipal hosts
for purposes of limited electoral
electrical energy producers
this bill amends the definition of
political subdivision as used in the
definition of a municipal host
because this bill is so short i will
just say that from what i'm looking at
here the bill
um
oh i'd see senator award just walked in
so senator avar would you like to speak
absolutely i was doing it in your uh
absence but you're certainly welcome to
come here and do it now
no it's great
and for the record i'm senator kevin
average i represent district 12.
and i am the prime sponsor
of this bill
and uh
i just got some talking points and i do
have a couple of other bills to
introduce so
i'm going to ask you to be favorable to
this and just vote for it
just
thank you very much
elvis has left the building so thank you
members of the committee i am here today
to to introduce senate bill 259
senate bill 259 is a small housekeeping
item related to the passage of hb 315
that we passed last year
hb 315 touched on many energy related
issues
but today's bill focuses solely on what
is considered to be eligible municipal
customers under the expanded net
metering provision
while hb 315 raised the net metering cap
from one to five megawatts it limited
parties participating
participating customers exclusively to
political subdivisions
which is important so under hb 315
political subdivisions are defined as
quote any city town county school
district charitable public schools
villages a village district sau or any
district are entitled to create a
special purpose administered or funded
by any of the above named government
units
as originally introduced sb 259
sought to slightly amend this definition
by adding
the state of new hampshire and offering
charity as the eligible housing
authorities
the bill was also amended in the senate
to include the peace development
authority and similar quasi-public
entities to the definition and i hope
you will support this bill
uh representative vox name
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you for being here and for introducing
this bill um i have a related problem in
my area of the uh
of the state
where we have multiple
service territories that do not coincide
with municipal lines and i'm wondering
if you would support an amendment
that would remove line the one sentence
on lines six through eight
which specifies that a municipal host
shall be located in the same
municipality
as the group members
for our
group hosts we only require that they be
part of the same service territory
there's no requirement that they'd be in
the same service territory and in the
same municipality
and since county and state are here it
seems to introduce an inconsistency in
the bill and removing this one sentence
would eliminate that problem
and i'm wondering if you might support
that amendment if all of you do
all of this how about a majority
the majority if you if you support it
then i'm not married to it if you want
to
i want to build a pass and i know that
there was some heartburn with quasi
public entities
so uh if you want to change that to uh
maybe university system which you know
i'm again it's uh
it's up to your discretion you know i
just want to make this this malleable
and and
eligible
for uh yeah it's in there
yeah if you have heartburn with that
just uh let us know i know senator
perkins cuoco she was really concerned
about the university systems
and uh that that might disqualify them
i'm not really sure if it does or not so
that's why we put in the language
quasi
public private yeah public or private
entities so
with that you know i'm going to leave it
up to you folks and we'll we'll come up
with some type of compromise on that but
i appreciate the suggestion
if there's one more question mr chair i
i'm happy to take it but i got to fly i
do know you're busy
if we'll take one more question
representative pimentel if it's a short
question please yes thank you mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question
i i like the quasi public
youtube entity because it
it's kind of vague and i'm just
wondering in your opinion
would something like a mobile home park
fit under that
quasi
public entity i don't think so
i'm i'm i'm not i don't think a public
mobile public park
yeah i don't think that follows under
this piece of legislation but i
appreciate the question
maybe for future if you want to address
that in another piece of legislation
but i don't think that follows under
that and i think that's why there's
heartburn because of it's quasi so it's
like
what's quasi
so thank you senator uh for your
testimony i know you're very busy so i
appreciate you testifying thank you very
much and thank you
folks and it's really nice to see all of
you
all right
honey remember honey not vinegar
shalom grace to you peace be multiplied
okay i i know that there was a speaker
for uh senator perkins coca but she's
not here so i will defer to the next
speaker which is
i'd like to have
kelly buchanan from clean angie speak
good morning everyone thank you for the
opportunity to speak this morning my
name is kelly buchanan i represent clean
energy new hampshire
and i would like to speak in support of
senate bill 259 we see this is a
housekeeping item as senator avard
mentioned that clarifies the definition
of a political subdivision of the state
under house bill 315's changes from last
year and this makes the bill clear to
implement and removes any possible
ambiguity from the implementation
approval of these municipal net metering
plans
this more accurate definition also
supports the goals of house bill 315
that this committee worked on and helped
strengthen local choice energy
independence and opportunities for
energy cost savings at the local level
so we're glad to support this we
personally do not have any heartburn
with the quasi
public entity but if the committee sees
i just fit to change that we would happy
be happy to consider that especially as
senator abraham mentioned with the
university system that came from senator
perkins cloka's bill which was senate
bill 370.
so just finding a way to combine those
is the goal here
so i'd be happy to take any questions
and i appreciate the
representative oxnam
thank you very much mr chair thank you
for taking my question and it's the same
question that i just gave to the sponsor
would you support removing that one
sentence line six through eight which
puts an inconsistency into the bill
sure i haven't had an opportunity to
fully digest that change but i would
echo the sponsor in saying that if it
was
the majority opinion of this committee
we certainly would support that thank
you very much
representative plett
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question this is a clerk question i
was trying to scan your letter testimony
and i missed what you said about senate
bill 370. so would you repeat that
please yes uh of course thank you
representative senate bill 370 was um a
bill from represent or excuse me senator
perkins quoca
that
also attempted to clarify the definition
of a political subdivision and on the
senate side of things when both of these
bills were heard both senate bill 259
and senate bill 370 there was some
discussion of that they could not be
separate bills due to the legislative
process and
which one would be assigned into law
first that could possibly
negate the other so the committee worked
to find an amendment to the preferable
vehicle which is senate bill 259 so that
they could be combined
and that has been achieved with the
addition of quasi public entity in this
bill as well as peace development
authority as a political subdivision
i don't see any hands up now so i'll ask
one final question
for my own edification could you explain
to me
if this bill passes what exactly will it
do
and will it have any effect whatsoever
on the electric rate payers
i do not believe it will have an effect
on the electric rate payers i think this
bill is entirely within the scope of
house bill 315 which this committee
passed last year and i think what's been
seen is that in the implementation of
house bill 315 the department of energy
has done an admirable job of
interpreting the language of that
statute but i will not speak for the
department but i have heard from folks
that have applied for these programs
that there is some ambiguity in exactly
what political subdivision means and so
what we're trying to do here in senate
bill 259 is to clarify that to make the
department's life easier to make this
process easier for those applying for
the programs
all while staying within the scope of
the intentions of house bill 315 which
was quite a limited expansion of net
metering simply for municipal and
political subdivisions
okay
thank you see any other questions thank
you for your testimony thank you very
much i'll call on mr roberge from the
department of energy as be our last
thank you chairman thomas members of the
committee for the record griffin roberge
from the new hampshire department of
energy the department is neutral on
senator avar senate bill 259
as you've heard and by way of background
house bill 315 was signed into law last
year that expanded net metering above
the current one megawatt net metering
cap
creating this definition that you see in
the bill
for municipal hosts which are customer
generators between 1 and 5 megawatts
that can group a net meter with
exclusively
with a group consisting of one or more
customers who are political subdivisions
and then within that definition of
municipal host there's a definition of
political subdivision
the bill obviously expands the
definition of political subdivision to
include state of new hampshire housing
authorities quasi public entities and
the pease development authority um again
by way of background since that bill has
become law the department has registered
for municipal hosts in the state uh all
four are our hydroelectric facilities
located in gorham berlin hillsborough
and milton
um
as i said then has been stated senate
bill 259 would expand the definition of
political subdivision to include those
entities you see outlined in bold um
again the department is neutral but we
did want to raise a technical concern
that appears to have been raised
already in the phrase quasi-public
entities
that that phrase isn't defined anywhere
in state statute and could be read
rather ambiguously
so if this bill were to move forward i
think the department would welcome some
specificity on what the legislature
wants to define quasi public entity as
additionally and i'm
at the risk of having somebody throw
something at me the department does have
an ongoing vdr study
that is slated to be released in late
spring of this year
and that will also help the guy help
guide the future of net metering in the
state
that really concludes my comments and uh
more than willing to take questions
representative platt
yes what's a vdr study i apologize uh
vder stands for value of distributed
energy
resources and that study uh has been
conducted as part of the net metering
docket
and that study should be concluded uh in
you just represented you're free to
speak
thank you so much mr chair
um while we have you mr robert yes
and we're talking about the bder study
can you give us just a little bit more
insight into
who's working on it and
approximately what it will encompass
sure so the department has retained a
consultant please forgive me i don't
have the specific name of the consultant
off the top of my head but um it's it
would be looking into issues such as
potential cost shifts that shifting that
might be occurring in the state
potential cost increases rate billing
impacts and that type of thing and it
would largely
look at
new hampshire new hampshire-centric data
rather than you know say nationwide
region-wide and that type of thing and
again slade to be released in late
spring of 2022. follow up
so you said it's new hampshire-centric
data regarding potential cost shifting
for distributed energy um
are you looking at any other precedent
studies
that other states have done similar i
couldn't comment definitively on that
just because
i'm not involved day to day in the study
but i can certainly follow up with would
you love to get some follow-up on that
yes representative
thank you very much mr chair and if i
might just follow up on that line of
inquiry
i'd like to say i've been involved in
the puc docket that created the vdr
study from the beginning and i just
would like it to be included in the
record it is not simply about cost
shifting or potential cost increases it
is about the value of distributed energy
resources and as other states have found
there are many instances in which
the value of those resources is
undervalued and they're so it's it's a
wide open uh mandate to look at
what is the contribution of those
resources to our energy system
thank you that's correct yes
uh thank you for that statement question
let's stick to questions for
thank you mr chairman uh
thank you mr roberts
i guess my
concern is it's something that i don't
power lines distribution systems
are not
uh
necessarily
to a particular town power lines
crosstowns
uh distribution systems will
uh
as for instance in
my town of henniker
i seem to be on a distribution system
that comes from
warner
and
most of the town
is
attached to a distribution system which
comes up from where
and i'm just wondering how does that
would that relate
to
um
if there were if
one or the other was a municipal host
um
if it if it doesn't cross town lines
so basically the question that uh
representative oxenham was asking about
i mean how can you
yeah it cuts that up i thank you for the
question representative so you know
obviously the language that
representative oxenham specified on
lines
six to eight um are you know it clearly
says that the municipal house shall be
located in the same municipality as all
group members so you know taking the
example as you referenced you know if
you're
a municipal host that's located in
henniker and you came into operation
after january 1 of 2021 you could only
serve group members located within that
municipality in henneker you couldn't
say have a municipal host in henneker
and serve say a group of customers down
in where and forgive me i live in maine
so my sense of new hampshire geography
might be off um but um that's at least
the way the language reads now
you know i know representative oxenham
asked about you know potentially
removing that language i'm not in a
position to articulate what would be the
impact of the removal of that language
today but it's certainly something i'd
be willing to follow up with the
committee on yeah
follow-up so so
the instance i'm thinking of is that if
there was a municipal host in
warner
and that's where my power is coming from
um
what would that
do as far as
what i would know not be able to
participate what would happen i i just
yeah sure so if you're a municipal host
located in warner and you wanted to
serve
uh political subdivision and or uh
political subdivision entities as
specified in the bill you could and
again came into operation after january
1 of 2021
you could only serve those types of
entities within that same municipality
you couldn't you know extend beyond a
municipal border or anything like that
unless you were
prior to january 1 of 2021
one more follow-up last one so would
they have to like redistribute how i get
my power
i don't think my power comes from there
from warner you're saying right yeah
yeah i
i have to
let me get back to you on that one
sure i'm sorry i apologize for that but
representative harrington
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh sorry i missed
heartless but i had to testify in the
senate um going to the bill that talks
about quasi public entity
um
as far as that i guess that would mean
the university system of new hampshire
so circling back to uh kelly buchanan's
testimony there were two bills in the
senate uh senate bill 259 that you have
in front of you and senate bill 370
which was senator perkins quocus both of
them sought to include new language in
the political subdivision
um definition in this statute
her bill at senator
perkins cuoco's bill as introduced would
have inserted
ccsnh and its components the university
system of new hampshire and its
components in any state entity
have one bill rather than two is that
they
put the focus of both bills onto this
bill
but they changed the phrase to
quasi-public entity i don't know
again one of the things the department
wanted to raise is that
that phrase isn't defined in state
statute so it's rather ambiguous so we
welcome additional clarity on that okay
follow up
well thank you that's i i didn't know
what it meant either that's why i asked
the question but
on a broader question and and you may
may not be able to answer this but i'm
trying to look at this and say
this is really a huge ex possible
expansion because if we're bringing in
entities like the university of new
hampshire and the pease development
authority they have a very large
electric load is there anything
in this will prevent them from putting
up say i don't know
four or five uh four and a half megawatt
uh solar generators and uh
using them as net metering forgive me
i'm sorry you said four or five
megawatts i'm sorry yeah less than five
maybe yeah less than five but the
universities new hampshire could have
like four of them sure i don't think
anything would preclude them from doing
so obviously the the
tariff for the the
the credit mechanism they would receive
for the power that they could put back
on the grid would be entirely different
under this uh you can group net meter
above net one megawatt if you're a
municipal host based on the language but
if you're just a private entity um that
wants a net meter above one megawatt you
can but you're not going to be open to
the current net metering tariff all
i have a question uh just out of
curiosity
since the inception of hb 315
have we
given it enough time yet to see how it's
working
i i can uh thank you for the question
representative again um you know since
the bill has been signed into law the
department again has registered just
four municipal hosts in the state and
all four hydroelectric facilities
again located in gorham berlin
hillsborough and milton
i can't speak for the future of of a
municipal host it's obviously as the
applications come in and are vetted by
the department and approved
i did check with
a member of the staff today and i'm not
aware of any currently pending
applications
okay i was just getting trying to get a
before we
add more to
what would be had been 315
to have an idea of how 50 315 was
working
the vder report will that cover that
area and
also when do you think that report will
be released so i'll answer the second
last the report will be released is
expected to be released late spring of
this year um and will the vdr study look
explicitly at municipal hosts
i couldn't speak to that again i'm not
involved in the day-to-day but again
it'll look at the value of distributed
energy resources holistically in the
state
i get just for clarification when you
say late spring it'll be really sometime
after
the middle of april
i would say so correct yes
seeing no other questions thank you for
your testimony thank you anybody else
have any
speaking desire for this bill
seeing none i will ask representative
vincent to bring forth the blue sheet
and the online information please
is this
is there someone did you sign up to
would you like to come up front here and
fill a lot of pink shape
please
well do it concurrently
hello uh thank you for allowing me to
speak my name is clark fenner with new
england solar garden um i'm a small
developer here in the state of new
hampshire please wait one plea please
sure
sorry i just want to make sure you could
be heard no problem um i appreciate the
opportunity to speak um again my name is
clark fenner with new england solar
garden
i'm a small developer here solar
developer here in the state of new
hampshire over the past three years we
have
built roughly seven one megawatt
projects throughout the state
with our development partner gssg solar
the comment that i wanted to make was
directly regarding that question about
the effect of 315 and the
recommendation that representative
oxenham had made
as we look forward into
the expansion of the municipal bill here
we currently have a project located
planned for
the
landfill cap landfill in laconia
in
meeting the requirements of the
municipal bill uh hp 315
we are currently laying constrained
there maximum we could build their uh
and get on the lines uh
working with eversource it's about 2.8
the
city of laconia has
committed
over a million kilowatt hours to their
hydro dams in the area
and we are
currently under the existing law
struggling to find enough off-take
within the city of the city boundaries
of the municipality of laconia to fill
out that project
uh representative oxfam's recommendation
of removing the line
a municipal host shall be located within
the same municipality as all group
members
if that line was removed that would
allow us to go out to guilford to allow
us to go out to a number of different
surrounding towns
in order to fill that out
second thing is that representative or
hp 315
is slanted towards the larger
municipalities here in the state
that have the load that can serve these
larger projects however the land mass
is really represented by the smaller
municipalities that do not have the load
and therefore
they don't have the ability
to participate in this program even if
they want to
and so my point there is that if
per representative ox
recommendation senator avard's agreement
about removing that line that would
eliminate that problem
it eliminates the issues where you have
multiple
service territories in an area
uh that cross over municipal boundaries
and it also
evens the playing field
for the the smaller municipalities that
have the land that can be a municipal
host
but they don't get the state offices
they don't get the uh
the
uh
universities they don't get the
community colleges located in their
areas and therefore they don't get to
participate by removing that line
now they can
that was my point
thank you
do we have any questions
for mr fenner yes riverside
yes thank you my question if there was a
cost shift to other ratepayers why would
we want to expand
this this is a
as the governor likes this is a
market-based
opportunity if the
towns elect to participate
as a municipal
off-taker
that's their choice they don't have to
nobody's forcing them to this just
provides an opportunity for them to
very similar to the community power law
it's a market-based mechanism which
we live in new hampshire live free or
die
and
you know if it's a market mechanism i
i have a question for you did you say
you were in the eversource territory
um
in this particular
issue for the laconia project yes we
have projects throughout the state yeah
i'm just curious if you if you've had
conversations with eversource and
what has been there
what has been the outcome of those
conversations
eversource um
is constantly raising well i won't get
every source
will do what they're told
that's about the best way i can state it
and
what's happening here
i've never seen them
enthusiastically support the expansion
thank you
thank you mr fruit thank you very much
testimony is there anybody else that
would like to speak that hasn't filled
out a pink card please and please train
i didn't expect to speak i just wanted
to say make one very brief statement
donna gamache with eversource just based
on the interaction you just had i have a
eversource
is working with developers in every
community where they want to there are
rules that have to be followed there are
timelines that have to be met and if um
they're not met we can't change the
rules or the timeline so i just wanted
to leave it at that
uh
could just for briefly
what type of rules uh if you could just
clarify
well there are rules associated with
every bill that you pass that when it
comes to net metering group net metering
they go through a rule making you know
department of energy public utilities
commission whichever one is i do not do
rule making for the company so i can't
tell you exactly which ones but i do
know that there are rules
and as part of those rules there are
timelines that have to be met
um and we can't change that um
regardless of who the developer is but
that's really about all i know when it
comes to the rules
okay any other questions
thank you thank you
any other
person or entity like to speak
seeing none i will ask for the blue
was giving the information
and we went on
uh
so it was 34 supported and zero opposed
online in the blue sheet one pro timothy
egan
yes thank you
seeing
none i'll declare this public hearing
closed
and
we will meet back here at 1 30
to start
sb
3 261.
okay good afternoon everybody time to
resume the
festivities
and we're going to open a public hearing
now on senate bill 261. this is a bill
relative to net metering participation
and i'm going to introduce the bill's
prime sponsor
senator gray from district 6 senator
welcome to
sdne well thank you it's nice to be back
in this room this is where i started as
a representative
all those many years ago well i guess i
need to move the other side of the
petition so that
you know
anyway
uh i am james gray i represent district
6 in the senate
which starts out in rochester goes up
route 11
into belknap county
this bill and the constituent who asked
for it is here and i imagine he will be
testifying today
um
but if we're trying to encourage people
to produce solar energy
and if they produce
and
use
20 percent behind the meter
that difference between what they
produce and what they use
is a credit
and right now they get paid
once a year
they've made all this investment
equipment
maintenance on the equipment
and
they have to wait a whole year
and i felt that was
unfair the original bill asked for the
payments to be monthly
i said well let's back off of that a
little bit and try something a little
different
so we settled on quarterly
and that's the bill you have in front of
you
the energy department will say well
because they called me up last night and
gave me a warning that it's in the wrong
statute
we're in the wrong place that it only
affects this and that and the other
thing
well
at noon time today after my energy
hearing
i went over to ols and said go figure
out what the right statute is
so that we can make this and
if we again we should be given these
payments
to these individuals at least quarterly
that there be an option for that
thank you senator gray do we have
questions for the senator about this
bill
i have at least one and that is
what is your expectation for the
amendment
right now since they haven't identified
the statute
i did ask the department of energy also
to look at what
uh statute they thought it should be in
uh so
possibly by the end of today or the end
of the week i will have a better answer
for you of exactly where the statute
you know what the statute language
i don't believe that it hurts to leave
it in the statute that we have
because it deals with whether or not
you're you're net metering
and mr
griffin roberts will
be able to speak more to that when the
great thank you very much senator
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm just curious
other than
you believe it's the right thing to do
what
what is the benefit of making quarterly
payments um are are these people um
uh
are they far behind in their bills do
they need the credits more frequently
and what does this do to the accounting
for the utilities they have to make up
those credits i'm just wondering what
the background was on this well i'm not
saying that they're far behind in their
bills or anything else i mean if they
they want to produce the energy
and the equipment that they have
invested in produces
or 70 percent more than what they need
so they're using 30 of that power behind
the meter
why should they have to wait a year
the bills that they get from the public
service company
show
what the status is
the
power companies said that it was going
to cost them a lot of money to do this
the senate committee was not
overly impressed by that
especially because a lot of that plus
and minus
is already on the bills but certainly
you should listen to them
but
my answer to your question
in short terms would be fairness
if you make an investment
to help out the environment to help out
your fellow citizens you know to provide
green energy
why should you have to wait a year
okay thank you
representative flett is recognized for a
question thank you thank you for taking
my question senator gray as you know
solar is very variable and it may
produce a lot in july and august
may produce very terribly in december in
january so
would to quarterly make the utility pay
a lot of money one way and
some quarters and then beg it back in
it may be that that very well could
happen
depending on how they choose the
quarters depending on how different
things are going
but right now
is that the utility company is
if they owe you money is getting the
benefit of that
for
a number of months
and you get nothing
nothing
you are making an interest-free loan to
them
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question
i get it you want to go no
yeah
all right thank you
um i i agree with you i think that it's
their money but um the question that i
have is that the language that's bolded
here says provided that the commission
requires the option of payment at least
quarterly
is it
uh like a shoring up annually that
creates a check to the customer
and would we be talking about
um
a
check four times a year or would we
want to ask them to
credit the bill for the amount that
they're
in excess of i'm just wondering i think
you know uh for what it is we're
what it is we're going to get if this
bill goes through whether it would make
more sense to ask for the shoring up to
be
done through the bill if i am a business
person
and i invest in solar
and i know what my energy needs are
and that
for the year
okay
or for any particular period
if i produce
and use the 20 behind the meter which is
required for certain things to kick in
and
my equipment produces much more
then that more is what we're talking
about
um
the
some of the technologies that are used
have solar trackers on there which
instead of having a nice parabolic shape
the
curve that you get out of it is more
flat on the top because the tracker can
can actually track the sun
and again so if you have invested
more money to get more energy
but still meeting the requirement for
use behind the meter
why should you
not be the one who benefits from that
until the year is expired may i clarify
go ahead i don't think that was the
question
the question is that the bill calls for
the payment that comes annually to be
made in a quarterly basis and what i'm
saying is
if the utility is already tracking the
plus that you're getting above your 20
or 30 percent that meets your needs
right behind the meter piece
if they're already tracking that excess
and they're planning to pay you for it
would it make sense to write the bill so
that it becomes a credit on your bill
quarterly it is right so it's not a
payment right it's a credit quarterly
what we want is for them to zero that
account out
on a quarterly basis
that some of these
individuals
okay have
a
net
energy
a negative energy usage
throughout the whole year
because again the statute the way it is
right now
is 20 behind the meter okay to qualify
for the the various things at the
certain power level
okay so
you know it may not be
that
a particular customer
is going to be
you know real high on the
positive side in the summer and real
low on the negative side
in the winter it may be that they're
producing power all year long but the
way the statute is
that right now the companies can do it
pay you annually
and the power company you should listen
to them when they come up they're going
to tell you that it's a manual process
because only a few people do this and
then dan
so
again and i'm not saying that that's
right wrong
but it's already on their bill
you can go look at the bills and you can
see the pluses and the minuses
and
i'll stop there
representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
wave it off
representative clausier is recognized
for a question
i thank the chair and i thank you
no
and thank you for the pause
uh center great um
what i just want to clarify
when
a person puts up
this array
knowing they
are have a raid that's going to deliver
more
they
must have
had that capital
and
already
paid
knowing they were going to get their
payment a year now
and that's the question if you could
just clarify
they knew they were going to take a year
to get their
credit
i agree that
in a lot of cases they knew
but that doesn't mean it's just it
doesn't mean it's fair and that's why my
phone does ring on a lot of different
issues is because they're neither just
thank you senator any further questions
for senator gray representative partial
thank you chair vows and thank you for
your testimony today
um one thing which i'm looking at i'm
looking at the uh
bill itself except it's provided in
paragraph five the customer generator
may elect to be paid or credited
by the electric distribution utility for
its
i mean that seems to imply that it does
not have to be a direct payment but a
credit i don't know if the answer is a
question somebody had earlier i don't
but
my more specific question would be
um
we're talking about the cost of money
and i know with my electric bill if i
don't pay my bill promptly uh there's
what one point five percent uh monthly
um
this we're talking about
the cost of capital here and would it
make more sense for a bill like this to
be
worked out monthly rather than quarterly
the
way the bill is written
that would certainly be an option
that could be available
we got pushback from the company when we
went
any less than annually
because they did testify that they did
it on an annual basis
and to do it monthly that would be
perfectly fine with me that is what my
constituent asked for
i thought that going from annually
right to monthly
with the expenses that the power
companies were saying that they had to
do this
and that a compromise doing it quarterly
was
what i thought was a reasonable
compromise and you talked about the cost
of money well the problem
that i would have if i invested in one
of these is that the bill for the
equipment
probably is going to come in monthly
okay and so it's not just the cost of
the money it's cash flow also
is that if i have to wait a whole year
to get back the cash so that i can pay
for the equipment
that that seemed to me to go back to the
fairness that i was talking about before
a follow-up
representative partial yes thank you for
the follow-up
um would it make
big sense in a way if you did were if
they insist on paying quarterly or
yearly
to charge them the same rate of interest
that they charge the customer for for uh
payments would that make any sense in a
situation like that
myself personally is that if we put in
the statute that they have to be paid
quarterly
and with the interest rates the way they
are right now it would not be worth
our time to put it in law and it would
not be there worth their time
i just pointed out to my wife
that her account that has uh several
thousand dollars and it earned 80 cents
worth of interest last year uh that i
didn't even have to report to the irs so
um you know
i don't i don't think it's going to be
worth their time
good point thank you
okay thank you senator for bringing this
bill to uh to us this afternoon
and we appreciate your testimony thank
you
i'll next call
on another supporter of this bill packy
campbell
and mr campbell if you could tell us
where you're from and who you represent
um my name is packy campbell i'm from
the town of farmington new hampshire
over in stratfor county with
representative harrington
um i will disclose that i had the
opportunity to serve in the new
hampshire house for four years actually
senator parent and i represented the
same
big conglomerate district back then um
and i just want to start by saying thank
you all of you for serving the state
i recognize the time commitment that you
put into these issues for citizens here
in new hampshire and i truly appreciate
the thoughtful questions that i just saw
in your time on these issues
and i'm glad that i come in and just
sort of like to talk to people so
i really want to answer some of the
questions and some of the confusion and
the first thing i'll start with is that
this is a different technology than what
you know about solar or what you
understand about solar so i have these
flyers that i'd like to just
and could you tell us who you represent
i represent myself sir
i'm the
father of my children the husband and my
wife and the
entrepreneur of my businesses i own
six or seven small businesses here in
new hampshire
and that's really what led me into doing
solar power
i own four car washes five storage
locations some commercial real estate
um and i'm a serial entrepreneur real
estate brokerage firm
the local rental store in my hometown of
farmington
and i still very much consider myself
just a small business a blue-collar
entrepreneur these are all service type
type businesses
and the the thing this business has all
those businesses have in common is an
incredibly high when you look at an
international level cost of electricity
for these businesses
it continues to go up and recently went
up uh a double-digit increase just last
month
we have what i consider to be
a problem in new hampshire with the cost
of electricity and we have a problem
that we don't promote distributed solar
so as a
you know
not to be political but a conservative
republican from farmington i support
solar not just because it's clean and
green and i have asthma and i want to
bring breathe clean air that's certainly
very important but i really support this
type of solar
dual access trackers because it empowers
people to have distributed energy behind
the meter and to be in the live free or
die state in control of their power
their power generation this is not just
about me this is about every car
dealership every oil company every
assisted living facility every car wash
every storage facility and even
um
you know mrs moffitt who owns a mobile
home and sacks mobile home park and she
can't afford solar because she only has
an 80 a month bill that she can't afford
to pay
so to answer your very first question
why do we need to be paid really monthly
is what i asked for
and the credit is already issued on the
bill every month
you you produce surplus electricity you
get a credit on your bill and it says
hey i'm negative 72.
so if mrs moffett wants a 24-panel
tracker it's not like you think of as
solar it's not like hey we're going to
put eight panels south facing or 15
panels over here you get a 24 panel dual
axis tracker it's making 20 000
kilowatts a year that's what it makes so
it is it's like kind of having like a
20kw generator in your backyard except
it's solar
so it's in in the graph is very
square like that close encounter the
third kind thing so in the morning at
six o'clock at night at seven o'clock at
night it's still making the same amount
of power is making it eight a.m you
don't have that that class like 11 to 1
peak of solar with this technology
you also
have very
consistent power throughout the year yes
you get a little bit less in february
and in january but these things dump the
snow they don't shut off for six weeks
in the winter and not produce any power
they lay flat when there's a wind storm
they turn and they track the sun all day
long this technology makes solar power
on both sides of the solar panel
on both sides
could you speak to the bill yes well to
speak to the bill the reason you need to
be paid monthly or quarterly was the
compromise is that you need to be paid
for that certain amount of kilowatts
that you generate that you can't wait a
year for that credit to come in
because the customers often do have a
loan and they want to get do solar but
they can't afford to do just eight
panels on the roof but they could do a
24 panel tracker and have it make
economic sense
and that doesn't change the cost it
doesn't create cost shifting it doesn't
push up against any of the rules and
regulations that we have i don't i think
this shouldn't even be a net metering
bill this should be a fair payment bill
and and you know the history of the of
the bill and why i'm here
is the law said they'll set up a
reasonable time for payment so honestly
i invested in some solar thinking i
would be paid in a reasonable time frame
i really didn't think that in rule
making and
section
504 b of 903 800 page document there'd
be a rule that said oh reasonable time
frame is one year that's not reasonable
do you get your retirement check once a
year do you pay check once a year
do you play the plumber once a year do
you make your car payment your mortgage
payment or your power bill once a year
of course not
so this is a very reasonable request
that we simply say that at least
quarterly and you know typical of of
that my experience in the new hampshire
house for four years i passed a lot of
legislation i know that things get
weight to the last minute
but the department of energy had my
request for a rule waiver
and under the under the law the rule
waiver was was very clear you shall
grant this rule waiver if it doesn't
hurt anybody
there was no finding that it caused any
problem there was no finding a cost
utility any problem i mean to say that
utility can't pay this negative bill
monthly
is respectfully
not a fair statement for anyone to say
utilities pay hundreds and thousands you
know tons of employees they pay they
issue bills to all their customers they
cut checks to for every vendor that they
pay stuff for and they pay right now
just eversource for instance pays
monthly to to 250 to 300
group hosts or community solar projects
they already have a system where they
cut those checks monthly if you're a
group host
the problem is if you have a 24 panel
tracker or a 48 panel tracker and it's
less than 100 kilowatts you can't afford
to go set up and be a group host
to just get that extra 100 bucks a month
but if you're an individual homeowner a
mobile home and you can get eighty
dollars a month and now you don't have
an eighty dollar bill and you have
eighty dollars in income you can now
participate in solar in a way that you
couldn't participate before so what i
found out at the encouragement of my
local planning board hey you do storage
we
have an ordinance that we want solar on
these storage buildings
so i said oh gee the state lets me build
a 100 kilowatt system
get that metering
do my math
not bad i'll i need some tax credits
i'll build this thing so i went out and
built them in multiple locations they're
now coming online
uh my first one came online actually two
and a half weeks ago
and from the fourteenth the end of the
month we made ten thousand nine hundred
kilowatts
it's pretty significant what this can do
and it makes it join the time of the day
when power is being demanded
the other big thing about the reason you
need this bill is you have to over
produce your salat supply side you have
to produce 130 percent whatever your
supply is because the 50 percent of your
bill is the demand side so in my car
washes if i can't over produce and get
that credit i can't bring the demand
side down
and everyone talks about cost shifting
when they talk about solar i don't want
to revisit that whole argument but i
want to stress this a different
technology
that if you can offset your demand
charges not just your supplies charge by
over
producing what you need you will lower
the peak demand for everybody on the
grid
this is the first time i can come to you
and say if you i don't think i can
reverse the trend of energy costing more
and more and more and i don't think
anybody in this room or in this in this
state probably in this planet thinks
that utility costs are going down
but i tell you if we have widespread
adoption of solar tracker technology we
can at least stop that double-digit
increase because we can literally lessen
the demand on the grid
so it's a fundamentally different
technology than what you're used to
i have now built
737 kilowatts of solar trackers i have
kilowatts
of 47 trackers deployed and properties
that i own
and i did this in good faith
based on being paid in a reasonable time
frame
and i think that i reasonably should be
paid and i would support an amendment
from this committee to do it monthly
and i would ask you to eversource makes
the credit monthly they make the
calculation of what the negative amount
is monthly it's on my bill
okay thank you for that testimony
representative plett is recognized for a
question thank you thank you for taking
my question would you support a charge
to you for the extra cost of doing it
quarterly or monthly
i don't think there's a way to quantify
that charge and to be to be frank i
wouldn't the eversource
doesn't pay me when i cut them 25 checks
okay additional questions representative
something i'm curious about now you're
you consider these small businesses
correct
what
do you know what the amount is that
would be due you
monthly
on a
on one of your small businesses
and then
is that in line with what's trued up at
i want to answer this honestly as i can
certainly when they give you the credit
you might get less of a credit in
january and february march
so
if you waited the whole year and say you
had a month where you didn't get a
credit and there would be months where
you wouldn't get a credit you just
wouldn't they wouldn't have to cut a
check i don't know
some systems it depends on the
consumption
but you have a very narrow amount of
power you can put out there now you can
only do up to 100 kilowatts ac and get
net metering there is no net metering
beyond 100 credit routes in in new
hampshire i think that's wrong but
that's the law
so i have businesses that use way more
than 100 kilowatt system can produce
so in those cases i probably wouldn't
get a credit so it wouldn't matter but
in other businesses where i need to
overpower the demand charges like car
but it is a principle thing i mean a
utility can go in and make a rule a
government organization can tell me that
rule has the full force of law that's
what they told me
and i said okay well i'll ask someone to
change the law i've done that before and
i think that we should change the law
when government agencies are creating
law
based on a statute that didn't give them
the authority to say annually if anyone
thinks annually is reasonable for
getting any type of payment then
you know tell me tough
but if you think it's reasonable to get
paid monthly or quarterly
i supported the amendment to quarterly
because that's how you get paid s-rex
and solar is quarterly so a lot of solar
investments understand that they're
going to get their payments quarterly
you can still get financing from a bank
if you're getting paid quarterly you
can't really get financing hello lender
i'd like you to loan me 150 000 to build
it you know some solar trackers can i
pay you once a year
that's not right so so in essence you've
handicapped
the legislative intent of the law
and you've done that through rulemaking
to prevent people from being fared and
paid in a reasonable time frame and i i
find that wrong
and i hope that this committee will find
it wrong and fix that so that more
people can get bank loans so that people
who don't have a lot of power can get
solar trackers so that small businesses
in new hampshire can benefit from the
law the way it was intended
i'm going to follow up because
i appreciate your answer and it
clarifies some things but the other
thing i i wanted to know was what is
your
average payment
per month so when you if you would now
in one of your small businesses
get back a check
what would it be would it be a hundred
would it be a thousand would it be fifty
what are we talking about
uh my current largest bill is about
thirty four hundred dollars a month and
i don't have solar on it if i put 100
kilowatt system on that it would barely
cover that bill so you wouldn't really
get a big amount back
but if you look at some of my projects
where i only have an 80 a month bill
then yeah it could be
you know 20 grand a year a couple grand
a month
on 100 kilowatt system but it would
again vary based on the consumption
behind the meter but the system is going
to be the same size it's either going to
be one track or two 48 panel trackers
the other thing that i think is is worth
mentioning is that the technology still
has to be tied into a meter so if you
have three phase 408 400 amp service the
biggest system you can put on is 150
kilowatts if you have a single phase 200
amp service the biggest system you can
put on it is about 12 kilowatts
so you're not talking about
fundamentally changing anything because
the technology is limited by the
electrical infrastructure of either the
house or the small business so for
instance we have a family dollar
building that's a storage facility the
most we can put in that is 83 kilowatts
that bill on average is about 400 a
month so on that particular thing we
would get rid of the 400 a month bill we
would get rid of the demand charges and
eversource would get to keep probably a
thousand dollars a month for me because
it would only be an 83 kilowatt system
but in order for me to finance that 83
kilowatt system and do what the statute
asked me to do
the state law says please go out and
build solar we'll do these net metering
rules we'll pay you these amounts of
money if you build these on your
businesses
so either you're dismantling the intent
of the statute which is what this bill
does
and then we find out at the last minute
we're in the wrong spot after a year of
asking for a rule waiver and sending
letters and doing this and explaining
the issue asking doing zoom calls with
the agency and saying hey where should
we fix this in statute
i mean i don't i'm not mad at anybody
here i'm just saying does that seem like
a problem with our system if you find
out the day you come in for the hearing
that it's in the wrong spot so hopefully
we can do an amendment and not have that
be the little bit of confusion
that i see created a lot in new
hampshire house that says well gee we
would have liked to have done it but it
wasn't in the right spot sorry you know
what i mean and i just i just i just
feel it you know geez gosh we can't cut
checks monthly that'll cost us a million
dollars
i can't believe someone said that with a
straight face
come on guys
utilities cut checks monthly all the
time it doesn't cost them extra money as
a small business owner i cut checks
monthly all the time it's the cost of
doing business it's in the rate case
they're doing it for all the group hosts
they're doing it for all their customers
this is no this is about as easy
you know a piece of legislation so i
think we can pass hey rule makers
you've got to pay them reasonables not
annually do it at least quarterly and
honestly if you keep that i'm going to
go to rulemaking and be sitting in the
hearing waiving my negative bill that's
calculated monthly and hope that i can
persuade the department of energy to say
you know it's probably better if you
just pay it monthly they'll have that
option in rulemaking they just won't
have the option to make it annually so
that's why i think it's a fair a fair
compromise and i hope that you will
support whatever amendment senator gray
can figure out and hopefully the
testimony we get from the agency will
say oh we needed to be right here and we
support it sorry we didn't mean to
prevent this new emerging this
technology is two times better the
reason i talk about the technology you
can have a solar panel on a roof it's
gonna have a one-to-one ratio you have a
solar panel on a tracker it's gonna have
a two to one ratio okay let's uh get
back to the bill if you would please
representative harrington has a question
uh thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
actually there's a couple of technical
questions on the bill
the wording says provided that the
commission requires the option of
payment at least
quarterly i'm assuming the intent here
is that option is held by the
net meter and not the utility
and it's i'm directing this team um in
the in the statute and i should have
addressed that in my testimony i
apologize you have the option to take a
credit
you have the option to carry the credit
forward
or you have the option to ask for
payment once a year so even if you had
once a year and you had a credit it was
if it's less than a hundred dollars you
can't ask for the payment under statute
so you can only ask for the payment if
it's more than six hundred dollars so
because i have systems that are going to
be more than six hundred dollars on on
some months i'm asking for the payment
monthly
you'll follow up so it's optional
i just want to make sure the option was
with the pain and so if i just two
points i'm trying to get to make sure i
understand your position you're saying
that the original law said pay in a
reasonable amount of time
and that was interpreted during real
rulemaking to be meaning pay once a year
and you would said that most solar loan
payments are quarterly so that that
doesn't line up with making your
payments when you get your check is that
correct
most solar payments are monthly i
shouldn't have said quarterly i have had
banks
that when i told them about this
proposed legislation that it passed the
senate that have said we could deal with
quarterly payments if that ends up what
it's being but typically if you're a
residential customer your your solar
payment is monthly all right so that's
the reason why it should be monthly okay
representative platt
thank you just curious what's a 24 panel
tracking system cost like that you
installed
um we've been selling we have five
orders for them right now and they vary
from 39.5
to 42.5
depending on
site circumstances distance from the
house so about 40 grand is what i would
say is the
um the average cost or investment that
someone would make and that would
typically get rid of their
additional questions for
this representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
it sounds as though you're saying that
the and i am i understand this from my
own you know research on the subject
that the tracking systems have a higher
capacity rate than a regular standard
array and do you have money money do you
have information on the
capacity factors for these types of
tracking arrays
how does it differ from like a
stationary array
um
it differs from a stationary array in
that it makes power on both sides of the
panel
it differs from even other types of
trackers on the market because it
actually has a light sensor and a
control board
that it'll sense the north-south light
the east-west light but does that result
in a higher capacity factor for the
solar
think of it like a garden hose if you
had a one-inch garden hose how fast is
the water flowing kilowatt hours and
regular solar it flows fast from 11 to
1.
on this solar it flows fast all day long
it flows fast in the winter time
the other thing about the science of a
solar panel is it produces more power
from 11 to 1 when the panel's at the
right
angle and elevation to the sun
so because these trackers are at the
right angle and right elevation
adjusting in real time based on the
light sensors they produce more
throughout the day they produce on
cloudy days they produce on snowy days
they produce in the winter and because
new hampshire is cold it's actually a
beautiful thing so in february we'll
have days where we have record
production
because it's cold and there's less heat
there's less loss
so that and because these trackers are
10 feet in the air they're dual use so
the other public benefit here speaking
to the bill and paying monthly is that
you can park cars under it you can have
a blueberry farm a christmas tree farm
you can maintain your wildlife corridors
you don't have solar brown fields you
don't have huge outside capital coming
in and exploiting our laws this is a
very different technology and that's
certainly
one of the biggest reasons i'm trying to
impart to you why you should do this
and to get back to representative
harrington quickly the law right in
front of the change says reasonable
conditions
including the frequency of payment
okay representative thomas is recognized
for a question thank you mr chair thank
you for taking my question
um
i'm a little bit confused uh you've
spent a lot of time
not talking about the bill but spending
a lot of time talking about your product
so my question is
does the bill that you want past
going to benefit
your technology only or are you saying
that
all solar
products out there even the ones that
are inferior to yours
would also
come under this law that you want passed
i'm trying to understand
why you've spent so much time talking
about your technology
versus
the ordinary monthly payment of a bill
is there something about your technology
that demands
a
fair monthly payment as opposed to the
older type of solar technology
thank you for that question because it
is something i meant to clarify this
would absolutely benefit all solar and
all solar technologies and the example
that i would give you is a lot of times
roof mount solar will they'll come and
they'll say oh you need a five kilowatt
system that'll get rid of 60 of your
bill this is what it will cost
now in regular solar technology if
someone has a service that's big enough
for say a 10 or a 15 or a 20 kilowatt
system the solar company could come in
and say hey we you you have a perfect
house
south facing you have this feel we can
do this ground mount we can do a 20
kilowatt system you really only need
five but we can do a 20 kilowatt system
and you can get a check each month from
the utility so why don't you buy a 20
kilowatt system so if you pass this law
it would benefit all solar technology
and it would make it so that the people
who had the capital the ability to get a
loan
could get essentially a small community
solar project
right on their house and take care of
their neighbor and their next neighbor
because the technology would benefit
everyone because of distributed energy
so if you have a 20 kilowatt system on
your neighbor's house and you don't have
any that electricity only goes from
point a to point b it doesn't go out in
the grid and drive up to canada they
they no longer have to truck that power
all over the state they only have to
bring it next door and they pay
you know 13 cents to the guy who
produces it they literally truck it next
door and they charge 22.
so there's a positive benefit to the
utilities because you're you don't get a
full credit when it's monetized so just
understand that this monetary credit is
a portion of what a kilowatt cost and
understand that utilities
don't make money on
transmitting kilowatts they don't make
money on that default service rate they
make money by depreciating assets that
they build and put in the ground they
put steel on the ground and they
depreciate it and they get a fixed rate
of return
they provide the cost
at supposedly their cost so
if they're only paying me 12 cents and
they're selling it for 22 cents i don't
see how that's not a bad deal for them
and and i and i and i think that maybe
we should ask them we actually have two
more people who want to testify no
problem
uh a utility so yeah if it's okay with
you we'll move on i would just reserve
the right if there's clarifications or
other questions that come up i would
welcome the committee asking me back up
because it is a complex
issue representative thomas and it's
taken a long time
for me to understand kilowatt hour
versus kilowatt versus flow versus size
and they produce more because
they're producing all the time and i
think the opportunity for people who can
afford it to oversize their system
that's something we should afford them
by paying them monthly for that we
appreciate your offer for your
your expertise
and we thank you for your testimony i'd
like to call next on griffin robarge
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee uh good afternoon uh griffin
roberge from the new hampshire
department of energy
uh here to provide testimony on senator
gray's senate bill 261
the department is neutral on the bill
the statute that this bill would amend
provides that when a customer generators
net energy usage is negative i.e
more electricity is fed into the
distribution system than is received
over a billing period then that customer
generator may elect to be paid or
credited by its utility
for the excess generation at rates equal
to the utilities avoided costs as
determined by the puc
um
the bill would require the puc to
provide an option for such payment on a
quarterly basis when it determines the
frequency of payment required and
obviously that's in the bold language on
lines eight to nine
as senator gray mentioned i did call him
late yesterday evening to let him know
about
some concerns we highlighted very late
with the language but it is a technical
concern as it just may not be what
senator gray had intended
as currently drafted the bill would only
apply to grandfathered customer
generators who were in service before
the alternative net metering tariff was
adopted in the pucs june 2017 order
it would only give those grandfathered
customer generators the option to
receive quarterly payments at avoided
costs only so we're only looking at a
certain universe of customer generators
in effect the amendment appears in the
wrong place in statute in view
of what we believe to be the sponsor's
intended effect
um the credit mechanism that existed
before the adoption of that of the net
of the alternative net metering tariff
in the june 2017 order uh carried
forward any excess kilowatt hours to be
applied as an offset
against future customer usage
puc's order in june of 17 changed that
kilowatt hour carryover credit to a
monetary credit that has determined each
month that is carried forward as a bill
credit to subsequent months for new net
metered projects so at the end of the
year if a customer generator still has
any unused monetary credit balance then
the customer generator reserves the
right to elect to be paid for the full
credit balance by its utility so on a
yearly basis you can be paid out for
that excess credit under the new net
metering tariff
and just as background because i know
we often come back discussing a lot of
these net metering statutes
many of these net metering provisions
set forth in statute have effectively
been superseded by puc proceedings and
orders that were established by the
alternative net metering tariff i will
point you specifically to rsa
362-a
colon 9
paragraph 16 and if that helps it's xvi
that language in that statute gives the
commission the ability to waive
size limits requirements and that type
of thing in certain areas of the net
metering statute which is effectively
what the puc did in its 2017
alternative net metering order um so for
example language in another section of
statute you know we'll be talking about
it in the next bill
imposes caps on net on customer
generator capacity and utility service
areas
doesn't apply anymore because the pucz
always kind of superseded that
again at the risk of having somebody
throw something at me doe is has
retained a consultant to conduct a vdr
study i'm just mentioning that again i
think you guys know my song and dance on
that one um but other than that more
than happy to take uh questions but just
wanted to at least explain what the doe
identified the bill as amended by the
senate
thank you mr roberge
so
you stated in your testimony that a puc
order superseded what's in statute
that's correct is that the root of the
comment in the
fiscal note
that says and i quote this would be a
change from the current pu
puc approved net metering tariff
provisions
and would
permit certain renewable energy project
developers and other customer generators
to net meter without sharing the
benefits of that net metering with group
members i apologize representative you
said you are first off thank you for the
question are you reading from the fiscal
note you said yes i'm sorry i have the
amended fiscal note as amended by the
senate i unfortunately don't have the
original fiscal note which i think would
have applied to the bill as introduced
that would be reasonable to assume okay
i'm sorry i i can't comment definitively
on that um just because the bill was
drastically amended by the senate from
the as introduced version so i'm not
sure to the extent that that might apply
so was there a fiscal note attached to
the amendment uh there was it i'll read
it this bill requires utilities to pay a
customer generator at least quarterly
for the customer generators excess
generation if the customer generator has
elected the payment option the office of
legislative budget assistance states
this bill as amended by the senate has
no fiscal impact on state county and
local expenditures or revenue
and i'm more than willing to share a
copy of that amended fiscal note if
needed thank you
representative plett
will the department be providing what it
believes to be the correct statute to
apply that is something we plan on uh
having conversations with senator gray
about but at the time we spoke last
night probably around six o'clock
senator gray i don't think i was in a
position to
iron out some language right then and
there
representative harrington is recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm just trying to
get back to what you were stating there
that says this would only apply to those
uh net meters in operation prior to june
of 2017 correct so
what we just heard from
uh mr campbell was he's talking about
newer units
and if this bill was to go forward
even with the corrections we're talking
about then the newer units that he was
referring to would still have the the
same provision of they could get credit
on their bill but if they wanted a
payment they would get paid at the end
of the year when it was trued up
that's based on my discussions with
department staff that is correct the way
that this is
again and going back to my earlier
comments a lot of the statute that's in
the net a lot of the net metering
statute has been is effectively outdated
due to recent puc orders such as the
order i'm referencing from 2017. based
on the change that this makes it would
only apply to those customer generators
who were grandfathered in
to the alternative networking tariff um
before the order was issued in june of
17. follow up mr chan follow up
i'm a little confused having been both a
legislature and a puc commissioner i was
always under the impression that the
legislator trumped puc decisions no i
understand that but again if you look at
the statute that i referenced rsa 362-8
colon 9 paragraph 16 it does give the
puc broad authority to kind of waive
some of these requirements under
proceedings and orders
one more follow-up
but you would agree that even if that's
pertinent if we were to pass a new
statute that changed the requirements
explicitly it would supersede anything
that the puc did i mean it could but i
think one of the things that we
recognized after the bill was in the
senate was i think there was an
intention of the sponsor to apply to a
certain universe of customer generators
we just want to be sure that's done
properly
it doesn't seem like from the previous
testimony that what we were hearing from
mr campbell was he was interested in
things that were built in the past he
seems to be interested in thinking that
that was ours now and in the future that
was our sense as well so that's one of
the things we wanted to identify with
senator gray and certainly you know have
conversations about potential language
okay thank you mr robarge we appreciate
your testimony we have one more person
who would like to testify on this bill
this afternoon and that's donna gamache
from eversource
thank you very much nice to see you this
afternoon for the record donna gamache
with eversource uh eversource2 is uh
neutral on this bill
and our only ask is the same ask that we
asked in the senate and it got lost
there but um so i'm just here to ask to
see if we could pick it up and give it
to us
regardless if
anybody believes that there is or isn't
costs associated with making these
changes
it shouldn't matter if there are costs
we would like to have cost recovery and
we would like cost recovery language and
if as some people believe that there are
no costs associated with it then we
would not get cost recovery but we would
like we believe we i've chatted with our
billing folks and it would there would
be a cost incurred we're not saying that
we want um to take a position on the
bill as a result of those costs we're
just asking for cost recovery language
which i can provide to the committee if
you decide to move forward with this
bill
and only one other very quick um
statement um it was stated by
mr um campbell that
we purchased the power from somebody
who's producing a dis from a distributed
generated
facility at 12 cents and we sell it back
to our customers at 22. i just wanted to
clarify for this committee that that
would never be allowed we do not do that
and if we are selling power at 20 we're
not selling power at 22 cents
the energy piece is the energy piece
that the puc determines is just and
reasonable the difference that adds up
to 22 is poles and wires transmission
customer service metering that's so
we're not selling it for 22 cents
because the the energy piece is just a
small portion of it so i just wanted to
clarify
thank you great thank you any questions
for ms gamache
representative thomas well thank you mr
chair thank you for taking my question
can you give me a sense of what would be
required
labor-wise if you went to a monthly
billing
um so our billing folks have told us
that right now we do this particular
type of credit
and and check writing manually
we would either have to
upgrade or institute a new billing
system to accommodate it or hire more
employees to do it so they could even
tell me exactly what it would cost but
follow-up
um
i hate to ask the question this way
but
why uh i mean i guess i'm not uh uh
the billing is
i i hear the billing is done
once a year
and so
doing it monthly
what what causes you to have to hire
more people and you get to buy new
software or just what's entailed just
show me why well the software that we
use in our billing system right now does
not allow us to cut a check monthly is
the issue we have
so that's why we have a manual we have
at the end of the year we have it done
manually we it's the way it is in all of
our um in our service territory um if
you wanted we wanted to change that we
would have to make changes to that
software or get new software or if we
didn't want to do that it was cheaper
because we'd have to prove to the puc we
were trying to find the most
cost-effective way to meet the
requirement if it is cheaper to hire
more employees to do it than we would
and you just heard from
the gentleman before me now not uh
griffin but mr campbell that the intent
is for this to spread and have many many
more um customers taking advantage of
this so we would have many many more
checks to cut and our system just
doesn't do it right now okay yeah great
thank you
thank you uh representative pimentel has
a question
thank you mr chairman uh
thank you uh ms gabash
so
just uh
it seems to me
i mean this could be simply done
with a software
upgrade which would be a one-time cost
is that correct
um our software upgrades um the upgrade
itself is a one-time cost but we do have
you know maintenance issues that you
know are associated with it but i'm not
gonna say the biggest cost is in the
upgrade itself i'm so i would agree with
you there
thank you representative berezni is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you ms
gamache for taking my question um if
it's going to cost the same or or will
it cost the same to upgrade to quarterly
as it would be monthly if the upgrade is
the expensive part
i i don't have that kind of detail in my
response my assumption is it's probably
close to the same but i don't know that
for sure
representative callie pitts has a
question
my question is the same one i asked
before do you know approximately
what the average is how much money we're
talking about per month
is it enough to make the difference are
we talking about fifteen hundred dollars
are we talking about five dollars what
are we talking about for the average
customer not the big businesses i know
that's going to
but for the average customer do you have
any idea if not is it possible to get
that information let me go back and try
to get it because i do not know but let
me see what i can do about getting that
okay seeing no further questions we'd
like to thank you ms gamache for
testifying
and
thanks to everyone who testified on this
bill is there anybody out there who
would like to say something who
didn't uh submit a pink card all right
seeing none then we'll close the public
hearing on
senate bill 261 we will take a
three-minute
of the blue sheet we're going to get
data from the blue sheet and then we're
going to take a three minute recess
before we start the hearing on senate
thank you
be back here at 2 30 for this in the
yep
looks like a lot of people in here for
the next bill
a lot of people in here for the next
bill
this last bill will come out of
committee with an affirmative
adp
unfortunately
but yeah once a year is not reasonable
maybe if
if once a year is reasonable i'll pay my
yes
okay
yep
yes
so
um
okay let's open the public hearing on
senate bill 2 6 2
relative to customer generators of
electrical energy and let me call to the
microphone
senator
avart who is the prime sponsor of this
bill welcome senator
and committee members and for the record
i'm senator kevin avard and i am the
prime sponsor of this bill and i have a
ton of professionals behind me who want
to talk about it so i'm going to
introduce it to you and a couple of
bullet points and then i'm going to
reserve all the questions to them if you
don't mind
just because they're a lot more savvy
than i am
so this bill basically has four parts
all which are designed to support
businesses in existing renewable energy
programs in new hampshire
first part of the bill addresses the net
metering for large business customers
who have a load larger than one megawatt
but less than five megawatts and under
current law companies who are who
install on-site generation sometimes
must put in systems which are smaller
than their needs because they need to
limit the size of the project of one
megawatt to receive a net metering
credit so under this bill 80 of the
power produced by the on-site generation
must be consumed
on-site
the on-site consumption requirement in
this bill is important protection
against potential cost shifting
this section of the bill also is based
on hb 1481 from 2019
which had bipartisan support but it did
not make it through the entire process
an important change from hb 1481 is a
recognition of the puc in the process of
studying to set the long-term rate of
the net meter and credit and under sb
262 larger customers using the net
metering approach
get credit
determined by the puc after it
completed its study the second part of
this bill's definition of small and
large customer for net metering uh to
state law these definitions currently
only exist in the puc rules
and there is some inconsistencies in
those rules between the different
programs by setting the definition of
small customers at a less than 500
kilowatts
the bill sets the stage for more small
businesses to participate in net
metering with the goal of giving them
more control over the energy cost
under the puc rules the small customer
level is capped at 100 kilowatts the
bill raises that to 500 kilowatts
the third section this bill also fixes
unintended glitches in the group net
metering law which does not allow
existing self-generators to join the net
metering groups this fix will increase
the efficiency in the system as more
cities and towns begin to use the new
municipal net metering law hb 315 which
we passed last year and the governor had
a nice ceremony for that out in the
dairy area so for example if a town had
installed a small solar system
a few years ago and now the town wants
to form a group net metering program the
legacy system could not be included in
that new group of net metering program
this bill fixes that problem and will
achieve the goals of hb 315.
another component of the bill launches
an investigation into making
improvements into the interconnection
process which is used by the state self
generators to interconnect with the
the process needs to be updated and the
cost and delay
in the current system there is a strong
support for from all parties about the
need for this update
and the investigation sets the stage for
changes at the puc
in the senate the bill was amended to
remove sections of law which have been
repealed in the past session in addition
the senate changes the investigation
into interconnections from the puc led
effort to the one that will be
undertaken by the department of energy
sb 262 had some opposition which was
associated with the section of the bill
which allows increase in net metering
cap to 5 megawatts for a single business
customer the opposition was about
potential cost shift however the bill
has a few protections
on this front
the bill requires that these customers
consume 80 percent of what they produce
thus limiting how much
would be net metered the puc will
complete a study this spring to look at
the potential
if any cost shifting related to net
metering
that study will lead to the setting the
parameter a permanent rate for the net
meter and credit and this credit will
apply to these customers
there are only a small number of
business
customers in new hampshire who need a
renewable project that is larger than
one megawatt so any risk of cost
shifting
is limited
making this change in the law around at
the same time at the puc finals
the final puc study is expected will
give businesses the lead time
they need for self-generation it can
take years to deal with the development
development issues
given that these businesses
start now will help planning up oh let
me read that all over again giving these
businesses a start
now will help in the planning process
and potentially provide the puc with
additional data for future rulemaking
for the large net metering
in contrast to those opposed the
committee received a letter of support
from several large manufacturing
businesses who support this bill and see
it as a method of getting more tools to
address their high energy costs
and i thank you for passing this bill
and i would like to reserve the
questions for some of the professionals
who can actually talk about the guts of
this bill
thank you senator thank you for
introducing this bill and we will asseed
to your request that we let others ask
questions or answer questions that we
may have
and i will point out to the to those
assembled here that we have 11 people
who need to speak in the next 42 minutes
so i'm going to be restricting
uh testimony to three minutes per person
starting with the next
person after the person who will speak
next we want to hear the
perspective of the department of energy
so i call griffin robarge to the stand
please
okay i guess we'll get griffin's
perspective later
in that case i call
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak in front of the sdne committee
in support of sb 262. it's a pleasure to
be here and it's been a long time so i
do see some familiar faces and it's
great to see you and some new faces and
it's good to see you also and thank you
very much for your service
i'm president and chief technical
officer of standard power in nashua we
represent
specifically today i think
keen but 45 other towns and 18 school
districts who some of these elements of
this bill are very significant too i do
also represent a couple of customers
that are as large as would be able to
use part one
which makes a lot of sense if it's
eighty percent behind the meter that is
a can is a very low impact element
um in the schools and towns i represent
the increase in part two to 500 kw
is very significant because it allows
many more of the typical size schools we
have
to participate a behind the meter but in
that metering
to reduce their electrical bills
on
part three
this one here is
a
very simple thing
if i put a system on my business 10
years ago when solar was expensive but i
did it as a statement
just to say i had solar
that
piece of solar
would restrict me from participating as
a member in any group net metering
program so for instance a customer who
has two meters this is a real example
that use four million kilowatt hours
each
and has a 25 kw system on each meter
that makes only 35 000 kilowatt hours a
year is restricted from participating in
a group net metering program
they would benefit greatly from that
group net metering program which would
help
develop other projects around the state
is also extremely important whenever we
look at a new project the the big
question mark on cost is the
interconnection costs and having some
process an idea of what those costs
might be so that an engineer like myself
could do a a quick assessment and have a
range of ideas as to what that would
cost
i'd be happy to answer any questions i'd
like to point out one last thing
standard power administers group net
metering programs for over 30 small
hydros here in new hampshire
and a handful of solar projects so we do
have a vast experience with this and
thank you mr hayden nice job two out two
minutes and 34 seconds well sir the
three-minute limit i've learned from
your leadership
okay questions for mr hayden
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
and uh yeah and you covered everything
that's pretty impressive
um it sounds to me like the bill is uh
sort of a cleanup bill that's put
together to try and address some of the
issues that have arisen over time as
people have been adopting you talked
about the early adopters being left out
yes that sort of thing can you say a
little more about
that
you also mentioned low impact on the 80
behind the meter
can you just give a little more on so
um
last first
when
energy produced by a distributed energy
resource is produced behind the meter
it has only an impact on the amount of
electricity supplied to the location
not only that but it has an impact on
the distribution and transmission
service it minimizes or reduces the
pressure on those things now i'm not
saying it reduces the cost because the
cost tends to be a fixed cost of
building those things
transmission and distribution but
reducing the pressure on it may include
the reduction of maintenance so it's a
very positive thing from the tnd side
but it's also important to the business
because it may allow them to avoid those
22 cent kilowatt hours we talked about
earlier in the last bill and i think for
a business it's probably more like 17
but it is pretty significant
what was the other part
uh the other part of the cleanup that i
mentioned was let's see
how the early adopters are unable to
join in group net metering and you were
saying
it sounds like that's an oversight or a
mistake that we want to it really feels
like it as probably the entity that does
the most group net metering programs in
new hampshire it does seem like an
oversight for
particularly large entities even even
the city of keene
who i also represent as a consultant
here
and stonyfield which is another company
i work with extensively they have legacy
systems a very small amount of solar
that prevents them for participating in
as a member in a group net metering
program and to your point about this
being a cleanup bill i agree it does
appear to be somewhat similar to sb 91
from last year which was
just to fix a few little problems
associated with some of our distributed
thank you mr hayden
see no further questions
i will uh call on our next uh
thank you mr votes it's a testifier with
you you're welcome
and now i'd like to get the does
thank you chairman vos and members of
the committee again for the record
griffin roberge from the new hampshire
department of energy
we are neutral on senate bill 262 uh but
the bill as you've seen does make
various changes to new hampshire's
net metering statute so to try to be a
little simple about i'll try to go
[Music]
so in section 1
which is lines 1 to 18
the bill extends new hampshire's net
mirroring facility size limit above one
megawatt for those customer generators
who have a facility with a total peak
generating capacity there's not more
than 125 percent of a customer's average
electric consumption
over the past 12 months
this language allows a facility over a
megawatt there's non-municipal host to
net meter if it has more or less
at least 80 percent load consumption
behind the meter
new the department want to at least
raise a technical concern with this
language as there's nothing really
spelled out in the section about what
happens to that system if a customer's
average electric consumption drops over
that 12-month period
one of these uh one of these businesses
that may
become a customer generator might
implement some energy efficiency
measures which reduces their average
electric consumption over a given time
period also there could be a pandemic
that occurs that reduces electric
consumption over a 12 month period so
a little bit of a clarity there as to
what might happen if say electric
consumption drops as to what happens
with that system because it's just not
clear
lines
13 to 12
define a small customer generator as one
with a total generating capacity of up
to 500
kilowatts and a large customer generator
is one with a total generator capacity
of greater than 500 up to uh 500
kilowatts up to five megawatts this
would be a change from the current
system construct um under the
alternative net metering tariff where
small customer generators are those with
a capacity of
less than 100 kilowatts large customer
generators are those above that
threshold up to one megawatt um i also
wanted to note that there is i believe a
typo on line 14
it says the term small generator shall
apply to a customer generator i'm not
sure if that should be small customer
generator
on that line just to make it consistent
um additionally you know we have the
definition of customer generator here
on line three in this section then we're
inserting two additional definitions to
two different terms
in the existence of another definition
so basically three definitions
in one turn in one phrase eligible
customer generator so unsure if that
should be broken out so um that is at
least the points i wanted to raise on
section one section two
goes back to what i had mentioned on the
previous bill senate bill 261 and there
being legacy statute existing in new
hampshire's net metering statute that's
largely been superseded by
puc order and proceedings the language
being removed on page 1 line 24
to the rest of page 2
has largely been superseded by those
orders this language removes
some caps that were imposed on total
customer generating capacity and utility
service areas that's really no longer in
effect so
the department kind of views that as
really clean up
section three
just on line 19
on page two
strikes service and puts in serving
the department doesn't believe that
makes any significant change it seems
like a technical correction in nature
so again more of a grammatical
clarification
section 4
which begins on page 2. line 23
deletes the 100 kilowatt threshold
between small and large customer
generators and makes that threshold now
500 kilowatts
it's unclear what the potential
rate payer or financial impact of that
change may be as has been previously
mentioned there is a vdr study that's
being directed by the puc
that stays expected to be completed by
late spring of this year
and will help afford the inform the
future development of net metering
tariffs in the state
also you know increasing the small to
large threshold may exacerbate any
impacts of cost shifting to the extent
that they are occurring um and
additionally there was a bill in 2020
that's house bill 466 that sought to
increase this 100 kilowatt threshold up
to
kilowatts and that was vetoed so i just
share that for the committee's
consideration
section 5 which begins on page 2 lines
and goes to page 3 line seven
that provides that customer generators
larger than a hundred kilowatts
up to one megawatt with an in-service
date after january one of 2022 must
consume at least 20 percent generation
on site
the department views this as a as a
change in the current as a change in the
current alternative net metering tariff
which imposes a 20 behind the meter
consumption requirement on all net meter
facilities above 100 kilowatts to
i'm sorry above 100 kilowatts that do
not group net meter so in effect the
department views this as a
reclassification of the behind the meter
consumption requirements for different
systems into three different categories
it's implied at least in the language
that as we read it implies that there's
no load requirement for systems less
than a hundred kilowatts or between a
hundred
and a hundred kilowatts in one megawatt
that began operation before 2022 that's
one
the second one there's a 20 load
requirement for systems greater than 100
kilowatts up to one megawatt with an
operation date um
uh before 2022 after sorry um and number
three there's an 80 load requirement for
systems greater than one megawatt as
outlined in section one i'm almost near
the end
section six
permits customer generators to serve as
a group host
for any group of customers within the
same utility service territory the
statute currently allows group hosts to
serve any such customers as group
members so long as they are not customer
generators themselves a department's
belief is that the intention of that
statute was to direct net metering
benefits to customers who couldn't take
advantage of net metering themselves
the bill would broadly expand the
numbers and types of customers who can
participate in group net metering
arrangements
based on the hearing in the senate if
the primary concern were to include more
municipal
customer accounts in the municipal host
definition then it is possible to limit
the exception to only political
subdivisions that way narrowly narrow
narrowly
narrow
tailoring um
the exception to political subdivisions
section 8
which begins on
page 3 line 29
that requires new hampshire's electric
distribution utilities to publish
hosting capacity maps on their website
uh these maps would show where
distributed generation can be
accommodated on the distribution system
without adverse impacts and without
requiring significant infrastructure
upgrades department acknowledges that
this concept has been discussed in pucs
grid and modernization dockets and it
has been successfully implemented in
other in other states
and then section 9 requires the
department to conduct a proceeding
to invest the potential modification of
administrative rules to ensure
cost-effective predictable and timely
interconnection procedures the
department did provide feedback on an
amendment and the senate to address
technical concerns with this section and
would enable the department to
adequately complete the study that's
outlined in the bill
i apologize for losing some of you if i
did and uh that concludes my testimony
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr robarge excellent testimony
representative platt has a question
thank you thank you good to get my
question uh
mr robarge and i have to admit it's
clerk you did lose me part way through
there i couldn't keep up with you yes uh
this bill
a lot of some several other bills
concerning net metering in one way or
another tends to expand net metering
uh and would the is it premature
wouldn't the uh
uh cost of
the value of distributed energy v that
whatever it's called uh a study coming
out
put the uh take away the
impetus for a lot of this if it turns
out it eliminates cost shifting and
there might not be value in doing
something like this well that's a thank
you for the question uh representative
that is a decision for policymakers such
as yourselves to make the department has
one it obviously has acknowledged
throughout many bills have come up that
there is an ongoing value of distributed
energy resources study that will help
arrive at an appropriate value for these
resources
and look at various issues whether or
not
makers wanted to expand net metering
before the conclusion of that study
is obviously a decision for folks like
you to make the department just wants to
obviously emphasize that that study is
ongoing
you representative harrington has a few
questions
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
i did have a couple of questions uh on
the line six and seven when it talks
about
total generating capacity up to
including one megawatt or 125 percent of
the customer's average electric
consumption over the past five months if
greater which i assume if their
generation potential is greater than one
but less than five megawatts so there is
no cap on that so that could be 125
percent of
eight megawatt hours or 20 megawatt
sorry i don't know why my mic went off
um i'm sorry uh thank you for the
question the language on eight does
specify that the system has to be large
less than five megawatts but the
department
looked at the language and
assumed that there was a rough formula
to ascertain the size of a system um
it's the average electric consumption
over 12 months divided by 1.25 would
equal your system size so it would have
to be less than obviously five megawatts
to be in line with what's being proposed
my point is i'm trying to get at is you
could go let's just say your facility
again it has 4.9 megawatts uh solar
production yes it could consume
10 megawatt hours a year 20 megawatt
hours a year and so it could up to 125
for that consumption could still be
considered a customer generator that's
impossible there's no limit on that
that's possible
second question
a number of people have mentioned this
the previous speaker and you had
mentioned it on internal consumption of
the electricity
and
everyone kept putting out 80 percent
whereas i can't find it yeah no and and
that's something that the department
highlighted it i probably should have
highlighted but it's not explicitly
spelled out in the bill that's why we i
guess in talking with
other staffers at doe is that we assume
that there's an 80 load requirement if
you're taking the average electric
consumption over the past 12 months
dividing that or dividing that by
125 or 1.25 and that's where you get you
know at that figure but again it's not
explicitly spelled out it's not in the
game one more quick one one more
the uh there's a lot of places in here
where it talks about five going from 100
kilowatts to 500 kilowatts changing the
classifications shows up a number of
places in the build what are the
ramifications of making that change from
a small customer generator whose
facility has a total maximum capacity of
not more than 100 to not more than 500.
so in essence the way the department
reads it is that if you are expanding
the one the current 100 kilowatt i'm
sorry kilowatt threshold that's
currently in statute that
as i mentioned in the last last bill the
puc does have the ability to modify that
size limit but hasn't exercised that yet
um if they do increase it to 500
megawatts you in essence be taking the
alternative net metering tariff that's
in place today
the tariff that's in existence for those
less than 100 kilowatts you would be
expanding that tariff for systems up to
500 kilos so they would be did we be
paying the higher rate to more people or
to bigger systems you would be paying
yes the alternative net metering tariff
customer charge demand charge full
credit on default service 25
distribution and full credit on
transmission no credit on non-bypassable
charges okay so there would be
a
substantial increase in what was being
paid to those between 100 and 500
okay additional questions for mr robarge
mr lewicky representative the wiki uh
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
roberge um one thing i start wondering
about is we talk about the electricity
consumption the only electricity
consumption that we can measure is at
the meter and we don't have how could we
possibly know how much energy is being
consumed behind the meter when they're
making their own and they're buying some
from the electric company and selling
some to the electric company well i
believe that the
uh puc order that was issued in uh june
of 2017 required by directional mirrors
to kind of measure the input and output
that goes on to the grid that comes in
from the grid and that type of thing so
i imagine those types of meters you know
measure that accurately
follow-up
if that was the question you were asking
no that's really not the question
because we can only measure at the
interface to the grid yes and so we do
not know how much that customer is
consuming internally if they're
generating their own energy internally
and using some proportion of it if they
we don't know whether they're using ten
percent uh of supplying ten percent of
their own energy or uh
100 of it yes so i again now i
understand your question thank you
representative um yeah again
there
there would be a lot more load
requirements in this bill because we are
the bill proposes to segregate out
different systems with various load
requirements
so yeah there
may be a bit of difficulty but i
couldn't answer that definitively right
here and now i'd like to talk to more
okay thank you representative callie
pitts is recognized
quickly we keep mentioning cost shifting
is there any
any uh projection as to what this bill
if it would indeed add to cause cost
shifting
and
would it be wise i'm going to just
follow up with the second question you
can answer them both
would it be wise to wait for the study
to come out before taking action on this
bill thank you representative um i think
i think that's what the department is at
least
at least explain to policy makers that
there is this study coming out you know
that study might will help inform the
extent of cost shifting if it is
occurring
expanding that mirroring before the
release of that study would likely
exacerbate cost shifting if it is
occurring
if it is occurring yes
okay mr robarge we thank you very much
we're going to move on because we have
11 more people who want to testify in
the next 30 minutes i will next call on
doria brown from nashua miss brown nice
and i'm sorry sorry i apologize but i
hello i'm doria brown i'm the energy
manager for the city of nashua and i'm
going to take you guys a little bit away
from the numbers and tell you a story
about the city of nashua's energy
journey so we purchased two
hydroelectric dams and you all are
actually a part of this journey as well
because last year you allowed us to be
able to net meter our larger dam which
is mine falls which can generate about
15 million kilowatt hours every single
year
so now she was a little bit unique
because we are the only community that
owns our own hydroelectric and has
generation of
this
monumental like
amount and
as we leave our contract that we are
currently in at mine falls we actually
have to create a net metering group to
be able to put energy into the grid
we'd love to be able to use our city
buildings and our school portfolio
is that matching mine falls but a lot of
our school buildings have solar on them
so we would not be able to use them to
create a net metering group because
they're generators so this bill would
allow us to
be able to create that net metering
group and put energy into
the grid and take advantage of the net
metering rules that were changed last
year so that's the end of my testimony
great thank you that's a nice story
representative mcgee um
miss brown can you thank you mr chairman
uh miss brown can you comment on whether
the
changing the
small generator cap from 100 kilowatts
to 500 kilowatts would have any effect
on your plant and your efforts to group
net meter
i i don't think that would have any
effect
on us
because we
already are able to net meter over that
megawatt as a community
and um
i i don't think changing that cap would
help
the city of nashua but it would
definitely help
commute our community who are not in the
city portfolio
okay thank
you okay so you know further questions
we appreciate you being here ms brown
mari bruner from
oh
it's red when it's on it's opposite in
the city of keene sorry about that my
name is mary brenner i'm the senior
planner for the city of keene and i'm
here today to speak in support of sb
262.
there's a few different things in this
bill that would help the city but i'm
going to speak specifically to the
provision that would allow a customer
generator to still participate in group
net metering
i believe that senator avard mentioned
he mentioned you know if there's a small
legacy system that could impact someone
well that's the city of keem story we
have a
10 kilowatt solar pv array on our city
hall that was installed back in june of
2010. this was really just a
demonstration project it was never meant
to be a significant contributor to our
electricity
demand
and and really that tiny little solar
array that's just a small fraction of
what our city hall facility consumes
is preventing us from having our city
hall building participate in group net
metering
so the city of keene just started i
think you heard from our consultant
earlier
this evening and and the city of keene
just started group net metering and
we're not able to include our city hall
meter in that we have a couple other
meters that aren't able to participate
for the same reason but i think that
i'll just stop there that's really what
i wanted to say tonight and um happy to
take any questions
well thank you appreciate you being here
any questions for miss bruner hope i
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony and we'll move on
i love it when
testimony is succinct and to the point
now i'll call on shane hardner from
welcome to sdne thank you
i have a copy of the letter that was
referenced earlier from five of the
major corporate
three minutes please yes
uh chairman vos vice chairman thomas
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify today on sb
262. my name is shea hardner and i'm
pleased to represent my employer worth
in industries in support of this bill
worthen is 155 year old family-owned
manufacturing firm employing
approximately 200 people in new
hampshire with our headquarters and two
largest manufacturing facilities located
just down the road in nashua
as a manufacturer of specialty adhesives
coatings coated products and
thermoplastic extruded products
electricity is a significant part of our
operating costs
renewable energy helps businesses like
ours cut costs and decrease our exposure
to the ups and downs of energy prices
renewable energy is also an essential
ingredient to meeting our sustainability
goals which are predicated both on our
belief that worthen has a responsibility
to reduce our carbon emissions and on
the expectations of our key global
customers well-known brands and footwear
construction products and consumer goods
among others who increasingly require
that we contribute to their
sustainability goals as part of their
worthen has a one megawatt rooftop solar
array on one of our nashua facilities
but our plant could easily use more
energy from a larger system and we are a
comparatively small electricity user
relative to some other companies that
operate here in new hampshire
if sb 262 passes and raises the one
megawatt cap we could explore investing
in a larger array than our current
system
sb 262 would enable other existing large
electricity users and those that might
be considering locating here in new
hampshire to control a larger percentage
of their energy costs and also make
significant progress on their renewable
energy and emission reduction goals
both of these impacts will help make new
hampshire companies more competitive
suppliers in the global market
as a manufacturer we think about the
cost of electricity a lot renewable
energy provides tangible benefits
through price predictability reduced air
pollution and improved public health
we found that investing in on-site solar
energy has helped our company insulate
ourselves from some of the business
risks of high electricity prices
new hampshire should foster these kinds
of investments to stay competitive and
ensure we don't lose the companies jobs
and employees of the future to states
with stronger clean energy policies
as you consider how best to promote
economic growth in our state i ask that
you consider how strong clean energy
policies keep the business community
strong and i hope you will all support
perfect
two minutes and 30 seconds
i love it
questions for
representative harrington
uh thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh actually two parts
first uh
you mentioned in your letter that 80
threshold to avoid uh of self
consumption
to avoid cost shifting can you address
me to the part of the law right this i
asked the question for the gentleman of
doe he said he couldn't find it in the
bill do you know where it's located i
cannot direct you to that exact okay
follow up mr chairman
there is
i would believe and tell me if i'm wrong
but i believe there's absolutely nothing
that stops your company or any other
company from putting in as much solar as
they want
you know
conforming to local zoning laws that
there's this law is not required for you
to put in a 5 or 6 or 10 or 15 megawatt
solar system provided you comply with
all the local zoning requirements
it does not prevent us from the proposed
law and we could put it however much we
want but you can't net meter if it's
larger than a megawatt i understand but
there's nothing that stops you from
doing that and can producing as much
electricity as you need to to power your
facility correct okay then it just means
that when we aren't
like
when we're not when we're generating
electricity but not using it like on the
additional questions
seeing none we will move on and thank
you very much for your testimony and
next up
let's have
a
dynamic duo do some testifying for us
killed two birds with one stone
but i'm still gonna restrict you to
three minutes
all right
um thank you mr chairman and committee
for allowing us to speak to this bill um
my name is dan clapp i've been leading
revision energy brentwood and enfield
locations since 2009
where employee owned b corp
servicing both residential and
commercial customers across three states
senate bills 262 is not about
race or the value of distributed energy
resources as everyone has mentioned
earlier
that is being addressed in docket 16576
it's a puc
this bill is about making structural
changes to the net metering rules that
allow businesses to manage their energy
costs
lock in long-term predictable
energy savings and with behind the meter
solar over the last two months alone our
new hampshire businesses especially in
unisource and ever to ever ever source
territory have seen default energy
prices in the range of 21 to 22 cents
per kilowatt hour in in february in
in february and 12 to 13 and a half
cents per kilowatt hour just last month
so yes the energy default rates will go
back to the seven to nine cent range
but we know that it's going to continue
to be
unpredictable in the foreseeable future
especially with
natural gas
capacity constraints
this bill will encourage on
on-site
rooftop behind the meter solar storage
that can allow businesses to hedge and
lock in their energy costs businesses
are asking for this
as you've just seen with prior testimony
um
one thing i do want to mention is you
know if you look at the iso new england
pv forecast report
from 2021 it estimates that by 2030 new
hampshire will see
200 and about 300 megawatts of installed
solar capacity so we're about 3x where
we're at now
that is the last
place last in new england out of all
states and the next
state above us would be rhode island at
north of 600 megawatts of installed
capacity what does this mean
this means that while every other state
is working in adopting smart policy to
reduce peak load new hampshire is way
behind and what we're going to see is
all these transmission costs get shifted
to new hampshire ratepayers over the
foreseeable future we need to act now we
need to be smart and encourage and
expand
on site behind the meter solar
so i'm not going to go through um the 30
seconds in four sections
obviously
so i'll just i'll just remind that in
statute 362 a9 it spells out the general
court finds it is in the public's best
interest
to stimulate the deployment of ders
distributed energy resources in new
hampshire and eliminate unreasonable
barriers
so
thank you and we'll open it up for
questions okay two minutes and 58
seconds
yeah two minutes 58 seconds mr monahan i
will give you two minutes if you need it
uh thank you and i'll try to use less
than that um as the community knows i'm
around a lot so i'm happy to meet with
you individually or if you have a work
session or subcommittee in this
let me start off by asking uh quickly
trying to answer two questions that
representative harrington raised
um
uh the first is where is the 80 and i
think representative in um
representative griffin he's almost a
representative of the kitty but uh griff
described that there's a calculation in
section the very early part of the
section which is the 100 up to 125 of
the 5 megawatts and so i don't think it
would be objectionable for us to spell
that out what it means but you do need
to do a calculation to get there
and then the the question with regard to
um there's nothing preventing a customer
from installing more than one megawatt
um
i think the
the answer to that from the
folks from uh
that testified before is right they can
do that
but there's a perverse hole in the the
system here and i think this is why
um
house bill 1481 was filed a couple years
ago and i think some of the sponsors
from that bill were here um the way it
would work now is if a customer
installed something more than a megawatt
and on nights and weekends they pushed
power back out into the grid they get
paid nothing for that so it becomes this
uh which we think was unintended that if
uh something is pushed back into the
grid there should be some compensation
for it the way the system is today this
there's no compensation for that so
that's what this section the bills is
attempting to resolve certainly as griff
identified as a public policy question
as what should that credit be um but
that ultimately is the big hole that
we're trying to fix with largest
customers that
have enough rooftop but then they stop
and i see my time might be up so
but i'm happy to
meet with you and i'll get ahead of my
client here and say that dan is
available and you can come visit his
shop in brentwood
right then so but thank you for the time
great thank you questions for these two
gentlemen mr representative lewicki
thank you mr chairman thank you um i'm
hearing
that people want to have rooftop we're
primarily talking about rooftop solar
and
what we need in the winter is power from
four to uh
nine at night and then if what good does
it do us to have a whole lot of excess
power on a weekend when the rest of the
so you're talking the x the
exports of the grid during the weekend
sure
that would be beneficial
to us
because then we don't have to fire any
additional resources to meet any of that
up okay but what is the benefit to the
grid and to the other customers and i'm
saying and who's going to uh since
you're gonna you always want can only
put out energy during the day when the
sun's shining
what happens at heavy demand times at
night who do we depend on
yeah that's why we we have base load and
when we build out our continue to build
our smart grid we're also going to have
storage that can respond to that as well
on off peak times
representative harrington has a question
uh thank you uh mr chairman thank you
for taking my questions just to follow
up mr moynihan i'm trying to follow the
logic of this uh page one
six and seven because i tell you it uh
i'm i guess i'm confused on it it talks
about the total peak
generating capacity up to including one
megawatt okay that's pretty
straightforward then it's talking about
125 percent of the customers average
electric consumption over 12 months if
greater than 1 megawatt but less than 5
megawatts
so
4.9 megawatts was the consumption over
the past 12 months you're saying they
could put out 125 percent of that
but i think it's on the count of years
yeah you're saying 4.9 megawatts is an
is there a
cumulative load over an annual basis yes
for the 12 months they would be allowed
to
put up to 5 megawatts ac as the cap
and just this this wording is is very
confusing i'm just i'm just trying to
follow the logic here one is in
consumption
which is in megawatt hours the second
one is
in production which is in megawatts as
you well aware they're two different
things
so i don't understand how you can size
a
generator based on the customer's
average electric consumption which is in
megawatt hours over a 12-month period
versus
how big this system can be which is in
megawatts
yeah so
um if this this helps this is how i was
thinking of it i have sorry i have two
million in my head so just for
calculation purposes let's say they use
two million kilowatt hours on an annual
basis
that weaken size and array according to
this language at 125 percent of that so
we could size an array to match 2.5 or 2
2 500 000 kilowatt hours that array
would be
about a 2 or 2.1
kilowatt dc array about a 1.6 or 1.7
ac
inverter size array to meet that 2.5
okay megawatt hours follow up mr shamus
we're talking about this really quick
the okay so what you're saying is you
take the amount of consumption in an
average for a year and then you'd say
using somewhere around 13 and a half
percent capacity factor which iso new
england uses for uh for new hampshire
turn that into a size you needed to
produce 125 percent of that consumption
and that would be the size of your panel
but not to exceed five megawatts correct
okay but it could have been written a
lot better the 80 percent consumed in
the
i defy without your explanation sir i
think 90 of those people in this room
had no idea what that statement meant
yeah that didn't work that provides a
little bit of a buffer in case you know
you've got evs coming in and
other electrifications yeah i understand
it now but you certainly by reading it
wasn't clear i i don't know who wrote it
but okay we can certainly clarify that
but i think the intention is to say as
we get into these bigger systems we want
okay gentlemen we have to move on we
have four more people who want to speak
in the next
eight minutes so that's going to be
about two minutes a piece and i'll call
good afternoon um mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is heidi kroll i work at
gallagher callahan and gartrell and i
represent uh here today the granite
state hydropower association and
monadnock paper mills
and we are in support of the bill
i will just add uh
two quick things try to stay under my
two minutes
we do support the section of the bill
that would allow
a small customer generator for example
the
you know fire station with a few solar
panels on the roof to also be able to
participate in group net metering
as you are aware this small hydro
facilities in new hampshire
participate in group net metering
and they have come across this problem
where
a small
municipal
facility or a school has not been able
to
similarly in the case of monadnock paper
mills
right now they meet about half of their
generation needs on site with their
hydros they purchase the other half in
the competitive market and if they were
meet part of their needs through a
groupnet metering arrangement
they would like to do that as well
and then the last section of a couple of
sections of the bill
simply providing some transparency and
some clarity and some uniformity
around the interconnection processes and
procedures we support that
and
with that i'm happy to answer any
questions or
give my time to somebody else
beautifully done a minute in 38 seconds
seeing none we'll move on and i'll call
for your two minutes
thank you uh to the committee uh sam
evans brown i'm the executive director
of clean energy new hampshire i will be
brief i'm batting cleanup here i think a
lot of the sections of this bill have
been addressed already so i won't be
redundant i think the one section that
perhaps should be emphasized is the
discussion of a study of interconnection
costs we had a meeting in the fall with
several medium-sized solar developers
and the utilities in which we discussed
the escalation of these costs that that
our members have been seeing over the
past few years and suffice to say uh the
the escalation has been uneven there are
uh different standards that are applied
by different utilities as to what types
of requirements they are putting on
solar developers when they have
medium-sized projects say over 500 kw
less than one megawatt that are
interconnecting to the distribution grid
a lot of those costs are things that
benefit all ratepayers for instance in
the installation of what are called
reclosers in in the place of fuses when
you have a recloser on the distribution
grid instead of a fuse when there is a
short the utility can uh try to reclose
it remotely instead of rolling a truck
which saves cost to all rate payers and
that is a cost that is being put onto
solar developers currently so a
discussion of how to equitably share
those costs as well as
what costs should be applied
uniformly when when
having this type of interconnection onto
the distribution grid is a really
important question that should be asked
and answered by the experts at the
public utilities commission in the
department of energy
wonderful
minute 30.
question from representative harrington
thank you thank you take my question i'm
not sure if you're the right person to
ask but well i'm going to give a shot
anyways on the top of page three of the
bill it talks about facilities eligible
for net metering tariff under this
section for customer generates larger
than 100 kilowatts but up to one
megawatt is that a typo should that also
be 500 uh i you in fact are asking the
right person only because the person
sitting next to me pointed out this typo
to me moments before i came up so i
believe that yes that is a drafting
okay any further questions
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
i think the points that you make i had
originally referred to this as a cleanup
bill and when i you started talking
about the
inconsistencies in the interconnection
uh costs and how they're attributed
sounds like a very important thing for
us to get resolved so
i wanted to sort of go back to that and
um the other sort of back to the future
thing that i'm aware of is um i believe
mr roberts referred to
uh hb 466 in a prior
a prior session which i actually did the
committee of conference on that and we
had originally tried to raise uh the
small generator cap to 500 kilowatts at
that time so it's not a new thing that
that be the
the rate for small generators it's it's
it's an effort to go back to the future
kind of
uh that we had tried that before and it
came back from the senate at 125 so in
the committee of conference it had been
lowered by the senate as is my
recollection on that and then it was
vetoed but so it sounds to me like
between
raising the limit for small generators
uh from 100 to 500 kilowatts and also
the interconnected piece those both seem
i don't want to say housekeeping items
but they seem to be things that we've
been trying to do as a state
for a while now okay and you have good
history so i'm just wondering if you
could comment on that i you know i would
add to that that the the puc was was
asked to consider this question of what
should the definition of a of a small
customer generator be
and so so it's it's one that we have
been grappling with as a state for a
long time uh i think our organization
our members believe that 500 is a more
rational cutoff as it would allow a lot
of these sort of medium-sized businesses
in new hampshire to get some certainty
as to what their electric prices are
going to be and i think coming into this
year when we've had such dramatic
escalations and what energy is costing
new hampshire residents being able to
lock in your price for 25 years by by
investing in your own on-site generation
is a really powerful tool for economic
development here in the state and and
opening up that possibility to these
medium-sized businesses think grocery
stores you know big box stores that have
a lot of roof space to host host a lot
of a lot of solar i think is a it would
be a
prudent public policy decision by this
body and
may
follow up and the last thing i would ask
is are you aware of what small generator
caps are in other states because i don't
know we often look around us to see what
other people are doing i i don't know
why we were trying to raise it to 500 in
the first place i i do believe that some
of the neighboring states uh i think
that question is better asked to to
folks who who perhaps operate businesses
in neighboring states but but it is my
rough sketchy recollection that 500 is a
cutoff that is used in some of our
neighboring states as well but um
i may be shooting from the hip a little
bit there
okay thank you
thank you
we have uh
two more people who would like to speak
and then one late
arrival
but before i call on any of those people
i want to address senator waters
senator waters is the prime sponsor of
the next bill
which is senate bill
264.
so senator waters would it be acceptable
to you if we extended this public
hearing by another five minutes to let
all right
in that case we'll move forward and i'll
call on the next speaker and that is
mark brown of the consumer energy
alliance
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is mark
brown i'm executive director of new
england for consumer energy alliance we
are a nationwide trade association made
up of both energy producers and
consumers
uh supporting all the above energy
strategies
um i'll be brief i'm not going to take
up too much of the committee's time i've
presented the committee before with
studies that showed that there is cost
shifting
i think the most significant one being
the study that frank wallach out of
stanford did showing that from
essentially 2003 on
all of the ious in california all the
dish the increase in the distribution
costs were attributed to behind the
meter and distributed generation
um i want to address a few things that
were brought up um
representation you brought up about
compensation above my one megawatt
purple requires
that
you know any facility above one megawatt
receive the avoided cost
so at least in new hampshire right it
wouldn't get default rate it would get
avoided costs for anything they export
so they do receive compensation
they do receive some compensation
um
i think one way to look at the cost
shift of this is we've heard a lot of
discussion lately about you know evs
and rightfully so that you know adding
evs
to you know incentives to
either have evs charging at night we'll
add more kilowatt hours right to the
distribution system and they'll be
increasing the amount of kilowatt hours
that are charged through the
distribution system we all know that
transmission distribution of you know
they're fixed assets that are recovered
volumetrically
so
i've heard people say you know hey more
evs and that will allow for you know
lower per kilowatt hour distribution
cost because you're putting more
kilowatt hours onto the system
to and then you're recovering those
costs through more kilowatt hours which
will lower the per kilowatt hour cost
i know i'm speaking in circles here but
just hear me out
this build would do the opposite of that
it would actually you know
reduce the amount of
kilowatt hours that are charged to you
know commercial entities which would
force those costs on to other consumers
on a per kilowatt-hour basis that's
where the cost shift resides
um i hope i explain that
one of the one of the things we've
passed community choice aggregation in
the state that should drive that should
incentivize investment in solar
um i believe the gentleman from revision
mentioned you know the high default
energy service rates right now well that
in itself should incentivize
um you know commercial industrial
customers residential customers to
to develop behind the meter storage
solar on their own and to self-consume
if that is what's driving this
um
and
the 100 to 500 kw change would actually
increase the compensation to those
facilities by another 5 cents a kilowatt
hour because you're talking about
another
full transmission credit and 25 percent
of distribution credit so it's very
likely that would further increase the
cost shifting and again the last thing
let's get to the study
let's see what the study says it's not
going to be definitive no one in this
room is going to fully agree with
everything that that study is going to
say but at least will provide us with
more information
to to go on
great two minutes and 56 seconds well
done
so i have a question for you
given the governor's veto of three
expansion of net metering bills over the
course of the last three years
what would be your expectation if this
bill should pass
he's vetoed similar bills so i assume he
would veto this one
seeing none
we thank you for your testimony
and mr campbell you have two minutes
thank you um packy campbell again and i
should state i'm here representing
myself but i do own a solar company
called bright spot solar that builds the
trackers
i do have very succinct things related
to this bill i both support and oppose
it
i would ask this committee to do a
subcommittee i think that we've seen a
lot of testimony here today that this
deserves further conversation
before you have a floor fight before you
vote on an amendment that's not quite i
agree with representative harrington
that that six and seven is confusing but
i think six and seven is the heart of
this whole bill if you consume
electricity you ought to be able to have
a system size that matches your
consumption i've had two systems i own
staples plaza i was limited to do 100
kilowatts i then went to add 62
kilowatts and then found out that i was
losing my net metering and it actually
cost me to add that extra 62 kilowatts i
don't think that's right i should be
able to offset my power and every
business owner should
representative lewinsky to answer your
question no we cannot track the
consumption behind the meter no one
knows what i'm using behind the meter
that's in general not a good thing to
have in law something that you can't
track you don't know and i oppose these
behind the meter consumption sort of
rules that is not in statute now it is
that 20 is in rules and i think that
rule was created from a may to a shall
the statute says you may participate in
group net metering the statute says you
shall participate if you don't consume
that's blatantly illegal on the face i
don't want to sue puc or anything but
that's an issue that a subcommittee
really should take up
um the 500 kilowatts would be worthy for
my interconnection experience i had one
interconnection system 500 kva
transformer 19 000. half a mile down the
road 500 kva transformer 7 600
there's wicked inconsistency and
interconnection fees that's a very
important part of this bill as someone
who's trying to become a group host at
the one megawatt level
to to go to communities that have the
consumption and find out that they have
a small 10 kilowatt system and they
can't be part of our group host is wrong
they should be able to
do those i really support what bob
hayden from standard power said that's a
simple cleanup that should be done the
interconnection should be done and i
think if you look at that first line six
and seven you can accomplish everything
else in the bill i hope that you'll have
a subcommittee thank you okay thank you
quick question
if there was one part of this bill
that you thought was more important than
any other part what would that be
the interconnection piece that you just
discussed
i would say interconnection piece
would be second i think first would be
that 100 kilowatt limit because most of
my customers need more than 100
kilowatts
and those customers should be able to
get net metering so that if they have
150 kilowatt system or a 200 kilowatt
system they only need that size because
they have the consumption and in order
to offset demand charges you need to
oversize your consumption
so if you did if you said your system
could be 125 percent kilowatts ac
inverter because that's what we use
that's what you should use kilowatt ac
inverter should be able to be sized at
125 of your consumption and if you did
that in section one if you're using a
megawatt or using 300 000 or using 500
000 you could then size your system so
your ac inverter would be 25 bigger than
that consumption that would be clean and
that would probably be the most
important part and that would be true
net metering and it would truly depend
on consumption
and yes if someone's power went down
later so be it but at least you'd have a
definitive way to size a system
on day one to ask for your
interconnection ask for your net
metering i think politically speaking
again in subcommittee i could speak to
this as a rep let's do something the
governor can sign folks let's have a
subcommittee and let's say he can sign
125 percent ac of your annual
consumption because that's fair supports
new hampshire businesses that'd be a
much better way to move the pendulum a
little bit without changing net metering
i support the one megawatt limit even as
a solar guy i support it because i don't
want outside capital coming into new
hampshire doing big solar brown fields
consuming this i don't support an
increase to the one megawatt limit but i
do support an increase to 125 percent of
your consumption
okay thank you representative callie
pitts has a question quick question
when you get your uh
net metering credits
and i'm talking directly to you
does some of that energy sale go outside
of
new hampshire
no
that that it you like literally my house
i made 43 000 kilowatts i have two
trackers it went as far to my two
neighbors down the street because they
consumed that power
so it doesn't go anywhere other than to
my neighbor literally or the closest
industrial use
the grid works on nodes those nodes are
balanced
that power is being consumed in new
hampshire that's why distributed energy
is so important not solar distributed
energy and that's what this is
okay thank you mr campbell and the very
last speaker on this bill is
representative tim lang
just like yeah get 30 seconds great
thank you committee members uh thank you
for taking i'm a co-sponsor on this bail
i'm representative tim lang i'm the
chair of the hampshire the fish and game
committee and i serve on ways and means
as well
um
this bill that's before you it's it's a
tough bill but the one thing i'm just
going to ask i'm not going to get into
technical details you talked about i
agree with the last speaker 125 percent
of consumption is probably the most key
number that we're really talking about
here regardless of the size of the solar
array um i agree with the other speaker
that spoke about the gap the fact that
if you over one megawatt and you're
producing more than your needs and it
gets stumped out onto the internet down
onto the net uh the grid what happens to
it how would he get paid for it what do
you do if you're above a one megawatt uh
array um
lakes region has a lot of manufacturers
that would benefit by being able to
offset some of their electrical costs
and i guess to the committee what i'd
say is that sometimes no is a complete
sentence you don't need to say anything
else it's just no
sometimes it's crappy governance and you
need to
find the middle ground in between that's
going to serve our new hampshire
citizens and our manufacturers and our
businesses here in the state
i think we know that energy independence
if we've learned anything by the oil
prices then energy independence is
extremely important to to consumers and
a bill like this puts energy
independence into the hands of the
consumer and allows them to manage this
a little bit better
it creates the diversified electrical
grid that i think is also important to
new hampshire and to to what's going on
so while i won't get into the technical
merits i'd just tell you to before you
say no
remember no some while it is a complete
sentence and sometimes appropriate
sometimes it needs definition um around
it um our consumers in new hampshire are
dying for some sort of way to take
control of their electrical consumption
and i'd ask you to consider especially
that 125 percent component how important
that is to manufacturers and large
businesses here in new hampshire able to
take control of their
you're starting to repeat yourself so
thank you very much
any questions for representative lange
seeing none thank goodness
we're going to close the public hearing
on house bill
262. what does the blue uh blue sheet
look like over there representative the
wiki
we have 52 supporting now
okay zero opposed zero neutral it's
still open until tonight if you want to
sign online
all right thank you very much
and now we are at our last bill of the
day
so
let's open a public hearing on senate
bill 264 relative to certain references
to the department of energy
and transferring authority over the
low-income electric electricity
assistance program to the department of
energy
and i would like to call on senator
david waters to introduce this bill
thank you senator welcome aboard
chairman and uh members of the committee
and uh good to see you all again it's
been a long day for all of us i know i
am senator david waters district four
here to introduce senate bill
264 relative to
the
low-income electricity assistance
program
um so what this bill does it takes our
highly successful
low-income programs which were
established in 1996 under
uh restructuring
and it puts it into statutes so we can
stabilize its presence
in statute
this is appropriate to do because we
have separated the puc from the
department of energy and administration
this program really does belong over a
department of energy
i will say just by way of preface as
well
um that this
version of the bill was worked out with
consumer advocate
uh crease and david shulock
and also input from raymond burke of
nhla and it was fully vetted by the
department of energy uh with its with
its uh approval of the way that we put
it together
so what is what does it do it takes the
existing uh program the definition of it
of in the size of it and puts it in the
statute
please note that there is no change
whatsoever to the funding
mechanism
that
if we get over a million in the program
then that
that
surplus is by adjudicative process
will
be returned
as appropriate
and then
also please note that in the
administration of it on line 15 we
wanted to make sure
that
what it has
it can do by a non-adjudicative hearing
process which is something doe wanted
very much to
streamline this
process
that it would have control over approval
of the budgets for how the money spent
and then if the program is going to be
modified if it's going to be modified
then they also have that
possibility
through adjudicative
process
so um
you know why do it i think two reasons
really one i've mentioned is that uh we
have separated the doe from the
poc and then i i think also mr chairman
particularly have thought seen that it
is probably a good idea to have things
in statute and so that's why you have
this before you today so thank you and
i'd be glad to take any questions
well thank you senator seems like a
relatively simple bill
uh we appreciate you bringing it here to
us representative mcgee has a question
for you thank you mr chairman and thank
you senator for taking my question
um it looks like on page
i don't know what page it is it doesn't
have a number on it
page one i think of of the
bill
uh
line
19. if the department of energy
determines that the low income
assistance program fund has accumulated
in excess of a million dollars and that
excess is not likely to be substantially
reduced over the next 12 months the
department of energy may
using a non-adjudicative hearing process
suspend by order the collection of some
or all of the portion of the system
benefits charge for the period of time
it deems reasonable to reduce program
fund
funds i guess it should be to the level
necessary to achieve the program's
purposes so could you say anyth could
you say something about
um
how that came about or why that's in
there although i i think it's probably a
good provision but i just would like to
know a little more about that i i will
but i i think i'll actually let mr
crease address i think that's what we do
now
i think that's just the process we now
we you know with the million dollars of
what we've we agreed on uh from the
assistant benefit charge for this and
it's important to keep that that
agreement in place and this is a
mechanism to do it so you're maintaining
as you said you're putting it into
statute
what you already do okay thank you thank
you
and industrial representative platt is
recognized yes just for my minutes this
does nothing but transfer the
responsibility from puc to doe
the department of energy makes no other
changes is that correct uh well thank
you it makes a couple of in in terms of
the adjudicative process and defining
that
uh that i suppose you could cause
changes that were necessitated
by putting the administrative function
okay additional questions first the
senator seeing none we thank you senator
thank you mr chairman and we will call
next on the department of energy mr
robarge
can give us his take on
good afternoon members of the committee
uh griffin roberts new hampshire
department of energy uh the department
is neutral on senate bill 264 as senator
waters uh referenced um david shulock
and amanda noonan uh worked with
don ray and senator waters on technical
concerns that doe had highlighted in the
language
and those
technical concerns were addressed
in the senate and
is in the bill before you today
as amended by the senate the bill
codifies the electric assistance program
or eap
in state statute and moves the
programmatic aspects of it from the puc
to the department
just for background purposes the eap
began in 2002 as part of electric
restructuring and it's designed to make
bills more affordable for low-income
households and potentially avoid having
their electricity shut off for
non-payment
the eap provides eligible customers with
a discount on their monthly electric
bills ranging anywhere from eight
percent
to 76 percent depending on the
customer's gross
household income and their household
size
eligible individuals and households can
apply to the eap through their local
community action programs you might know
them as caps
taps take applications qualified
customers utilities cover that customer
for
with an appropriate discount
for a 12-month period
as is mentioned in is outlined in the
bill the eap is funded by all electric
utility customers through a portion of
the system benefits charge on their
electric bill
just running through the bill briefly
section one
replaces a reference
to the commission with the department
because it's shifting the eap over to
the department from the commission
section two just creates a new
definition
for the department in that statute to
make explicit reference to us
and then section three
is the bulk of the bill where it moves
the eap from the puc
over to the department and clarifies
administration of the program so
you'll see in there it establishes the
eap's funding to be from the system
benefits charge at a rate of 1.5 mills
per kilowatt hour
all previous puc orders regarding the
creation implementation of the program
are transferred over to the department
it carries over various things that
currently exist there in statute so the
language on lines
24 that's the million dollar excess that
um exists for the commission now that
carries over to the department um and
then obviously on lines 25-26 any
actions taken using a non-adjudicative
hearing process shall be by written
decision and the department shall say
its reasons for the actions taken um
that really concludes my testimony just
want to give background on the eap and
none
okay sweet i guess there's none
thank you very often thank you
okay wonderful
all right next we have the
distinct pleasure and honor
to welcome back to our committee for the
first time i think this year
our consumer advocate mr don crease and
don it's great to see you again
ah my mother would love that
introduction so thank you on her behalf
uh
good morning good afternoon mr chairman
members of the committee i am don crease
the consumer advocate and as you know my
job by statute is to represent the
interests of residential utility
customers uh one including low-income
customers and one small way i've done
that recently is by helping senator
waters uh refine this bill and we had a
very
effective and pleasant consultative
process over in the other body to do
just that
this bill has an impressive roster of
bipartisan co-sponsors
i always feel a little more comfortable
sitting at this table when i know i'm
supporting a bill that has
representative kelly pitts among the
sponsors
and i regard it as a kind of a good
government a good government initiative
that's really in the spirit of the house
bill 2
language that created the department of
energy it was hard back then last year
to think of everything and i think this
is one that didn't really get focused on
that deserves to be the public utilities
commission as it's been reconfigured is
really good at adjudication and the
department of energy exists
to do program implementation the public
utilities commission does its work
behind an ex-parte wall that's pretty
impermeable the department of energy is
accessible when questions arise and when
programmatic tweaks are needed so that's
why i think it makes sense to transfer
responsibility for the electric
assistance program from the puc
over to the department of energy the eap
as you've already heard about it makes
an interesting contrast with the energy
efficiency program so this sort of book
ends house bill 549 in a way those are
the two major those are the two programs
right now that are funded by the system
benefits charge uh both are enshrined
and always have been in the
restructuring act
the electric assistance program has
always been fixed by statute at 1.5
mills per kilowatt hour that's that
program's portion of the system benefits
charge it's right there in the statute
it isn't changing
it has a much smaller revenue stream and
much more
limited administrative needs than the nh
saves programs do uh prior to house bill
2 the program has all the way back to
its inception back in the early part of
the century been governed essentially by
an advisory board called the eap
advisory board
the puc back in the day was actually
represented on that board that paradigm
worked so
uh it it makes sense now for the
department of energy to be the sort of
parent organization to the advisory
board and i think this bill has that
effect too
uh as you've already heard from senator
waters uh the bill was amended over in
the senate thanks to excellent
collaboration
with and input from new hampshire legal
assistance and the department of energy
uh the refund provision that i think
representative mcgee asked about is in
the current version of the statute so
the only thing about that
that changes in other words that
mechanism where if there's an excessive
balance in the fund the low income
portion of the sbc is reduced for a
while that's in the statute right now so
the only difference is that the
department of energy would have to make
that call
i consider this a very uncontroversial
initiative that ties up a loose thread
from the legislation that created the
department of energy so i respectfully
but emphatically recommend that you
report it to the floor with an ought to
pass recommendation and of course i'd be
happy to answer any questions if that's
the chairman's pleasure
thank you for your usual brilliant
testimony on a bill before us
are there any questions for our consumer
advocate
since this is as you point out a pretty
non-controversial bill there's probably
not a lot to ask
so i thank you thank you it looks like
we'll be able to
call next upon mr raymond burke who
represents the new hampshire legal
assistance group and get his testimony
on this bill welcome mr burke thank you
mr chairman good afternoon to members of
the committee um
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today i'll try to keep it as short as i
can a
consumer advocate crease is always a
tough act to follow and i don't know
that i'll have much more to say but just
for the record raymond burke
new hampshire legal assistance for those
who may not be familiar with us is a
non-profit law firm that represents
low-income granite staters throughout
the state in civil legal matters and we
have an energy and utility justice
project where we represent
ratepayers
in matters related to access to
affordable energy service including in
dockets before the public utility
commission
as you heard uh from senator waters um
earlier
the electric assistance program is a
crucial program uh in our state and and
we've been involved in it uh since its
inception uh many decades ago at this
point um and it's been touted by the
regulatory assistance project as a as a
model program for the region uh and
perhaps nationally so um we support um
uh this bill we support enshrining it in
statute for all the reasons you heard
already from those who spoke
and we appreciate
the the collaboration with the
department of energy the consumer
advocate senator waters and his
colleagues to
work on the version that is before you
now um the only other thing that i can
say um from our perspective just to
clarify some of the questions that were
asked earlier uh to the extent
anything is is changing i think
um where you see references to the
non-adjudicative hearing process and
this speaks to one of our concerns when
we were working on the bill over on on
the senate side um that's just to
clarify what the process is
with the department of energy
historically because the puc has
overseen the program
the way the puc operated when changes
needed to be made or the excess funds
needed to be addressed it would open an
adjudicative docket and so i think that
language is merely clarifying the
process that the department of energy
is suitable to do which would was as i
read it would be a notice and comment
period and we thought it was especially
important
to to make that clear and then also to
have the last two lines 24 and 25
stating that the department will issue a
written decision uh stating why it's
making the its decision and how it's
responding to any comments that might be
received
great representative blett has a
question yes thank you thank you for
taking my question because it's a
non-adjudicative process at the ue the
department of india they're coming up
with a written statement somebody could
appeal that to the puc and make it
adjudicative
um i i uh
maybe would ask maybe for someone else
to clarify so i don't misstate but my my
take on that is that
an appeal would not go to the puc but
there there might be an appeal that
could be made uh in in uh court i can't
recall the top of my head if it would go
straight to the new hampshire supreme
court or it would have to start in
superior court but there may be legal
remedies available in court but i don't
think it would go to
uh the puc would no longer have
jurisdiction over the program but if
well that's a good clarification thank
you
any further questions for new hampshire
legal assistance
seeing none we thank you very much thank
you for testifying on this bill
uh
mr crease do you have anything to add to
that last question about
appeals
only to say that i agree with mr burke
uh that basically this bill transfers
responsibility and authority for the eap
over to the department of energy so that
if a party were grieved by what the
department did
uh i think that you could
at least ask the new hampshire supreme
court to hear an appeal
of course it would be discretionary as
are appeals from the puc itself
would do you think that the department
would entertain an appeal to a decision
well you would have to ask them to
re-hear the idea
the statute which is rsa 541 3
says that before you can consider an
appeal you have to ask the agency to
correct its mistake that's just a way of
creating some efficiency in government
perfect thank you for that answer
you're the first person to call me
okay
well i think we're done thank you very
much so let's uh
let's
close this public hearing and ask mr
representative luiki to
retrieve the blue
okay we have one person in support on
the blue sheet and 17
okay thank you
we are done for the day i thank you all
for being here today representative
oxidom you have a comment
is there any possibility of a
subcommittee or a hearing on the
difficult bill that we had uh prior to
this one with so many questions raised
thank you 262. 262. yes we'll have to
give that some consideration
i will
let everybody know next monday morning
when we convene for our next round of
parent public hearings
if
that question warrants a discussion if
so we'll have that discussion before we
start our public hearings on monday
thank you very much
okay everybody have a wonderful weekend
and we'll see you next monday morning at
is